une production du studio sf bio venus
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités date c'est
super content avec moins d'hommes
plantes d'hommes cette semaine le
podcast prisons de quartier par nos
grands amis de chez terriens terriens
les comptables on les adore on fait
affaire avec eux d'ailleurs qui font
notre comptabilité très bien d'ailleurs
et puis tu interviens ce que c'est ces
bureaux de comptables avec plus de 25
ans d'expérience au service des pme
innovantes qui n'a pas besoin de leur
expliquer votre modèle d'affaires cette
épicerie de faire affaire avec des gens
de plusieurs domaines comme
l'informatique biotechnologies créateur
web jeux vidéo et toutes les industries
innovantes studio de podcasts radio
podcast
ils vont pouvoir vous aider à maximiser
maximiser pardon vos retours décrite
d'impôt r&d cdae et multimédia pour se
livrer savent vraiment ce que ça peut
être
et en plus c'est un système
d'impartition contre ça veut dire qu'ils
deviennent carrément le département
comptabilité de votre entreprise
alors que vous soyez une petite très
petite entreprise moyenne grosse énorme
gigantesque
ap les terriens terriens ou si vous avez
juste besoin d'un comptable points
appelés les sons sont allés coûte sont
efficaces sont gentils et voilà allez
les voir le ps merci terrain terriens le
podcast aussi présenté par dans le sac
dans le sax une compagnie québécoise qui
fabrique des produits éco responsables
qui vous aident à diminuer votre impact
sur l'environnement notamment par
exemple des sacs réutilisables
lyon aussi un blog sur youtube et sur
instagram qui donne des astuces pour une
vie durables puis quitte à avoir un mode
de vie aussi zéro déchet muschick c'est
quelque chose que j'essaie d'implémenter
d'implémenter je sais
d'entrée c'est à mon quotidien le plus
possible mais c'est extrêmement
difficile quand on sait pas par où
commencer donc dans le sac il s'occupe
de vous donner les astuces et de fournir
en plus des produits qui vient de si les
propriétaires laurie et stéphanie qui
sont les propres de l'entreprise donne
plusieurs trucs pour s'initier à la vie
zéro déchet s'initier à réduire notre
impact environnemental
moi je vais définitivement aller voir
ses astuces là parce que c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur
on offre 1 15 % de rabais sur toute la
boutique en ligne avec le code promo
studio sans filtre 15 donc studio sans
filtre en lettres majuscules 15 ans
chiffres tout ça en un mot donc c'est un
code promo qui va vous donner 15 % de
rabais sur tout achat sur leur boutique
en ligne puis tous ensemble on peut
faire une différence
donc on ne ment pas tout le monde d'être
100% zéro déchet mais c'est tout le
monde et le plus possible sans faire une
énorme différence donc allé voir sur
leur site web
c'est super cool les entreprises comme
sur moi j'adore collaborer avec des gens
même donc merci la gagne dans le sac
merci terrain terriens pour appuyer le
sans filtre podcast ci nomme cette
semaine on a reçu 2 entre sionistes du
coup complètement passionné 2 personnes
comprenant passionnés par leur métier
par cette science
le bernard laval et y catherine lefebvre
lyon un podcast d'ailleurs ensemble
s'appelle on s'appelle ayons des jeunes
c'est excellent en prenant un sujet par
émission ayant parlé d'un point de vue
scientifique n'a point de vue de
nutritionnistes et c'est super
intéressant je vous recommande d'aller
écouter ce mais surtout d'écouter ce
podcast
on a parlé de plusieurs sujets très
intéressant et très d'actualité aussi on
a parlé du film game centers que vous
avez peut-être vu peut-être pas si vous
l'avez pas vu je vous encourage à le
regarder c'est un excellent documentaire
dégâts qu'on peut dire en fait ce
documentaire qui traite du véganisme de
retraite vegas puis qui encouragent de
diminuer ou a été finalement sa
consommation de viande de produits
animal qui suit surtout les athlètes et
la santé que que les marges et plus de
végétaux vote à porter est le fait de
manger beaucoup de produit animal peut
impliquer
alors on parle du documentaire ses
documentaires là je pense qu'il vaut la
peine d'être vue mais il ya certaines
nuances apportées tant commandes a
apporté ses nuances lors d'un podcast
avec des professionnels de la santé ont
aussi parlé de nos sujets chauds comme
la perte de poids comme les régimes
comme la grossophobie aussi comme le
fait qu'on juge beaucoup les gens par
l'apparence et le lien pour toujours
claire entre oye et santé un lien comme
souvent un raccourci en fait qu'on fait
souvent mais qui est pas nécessairement
vrai alors on démystifie tous ceux avec
ses deux grands passionnés de nutrition
ouais c'était une super conversation
vous savez que le véganisme c'est
quelque chose que nous on parle beaucoup
moins tu avais gamme de mes temps
vais-je et puis on ne trouve ça super
important on en parle tellement que l'on
veut on veut recevoir des gens qui vont
en parler avec nous de façon plus
scientifique pour voir de quoi il en
retourne superbe conversation sinon vous
pouvez vous abonner à notre pétrone
pétrone c'est vraiment la meilleure
façon nous encourager encore une fois
vous êtes plusieurs à vous êtes abonnés
dans la dernière semaine c'est super
cool
vous allez dans le fond sur peinture
vous avez accès à tous les podcasts
qu'on fait au moment qu on les tourne
mais un petit peu après mais aussitôt
qu'on les tours dont les mets là dessus
donc en ce moment là dessus à un podcast
avec bob le chef et un podcast avec
catherine bastien un podcast avec mehdi
broussailles dame donc
à l'échec et ça c'est vraiment tout les
podcasts sont disponibles là dessus et
puis sinon d'hommes et moi on fait aussi
des podcasts sur lodolo nous deux
ensembles où est ce qu'ils m'ont est
disponible seulement sur pétrone donc
trois pièces par mois vous avez accès à
tout ça et dans le fond écoutez
laissez-nous des commentaires reading
partout et les écouter vos podcasts
ça fait son bout de chemin on est une
bonne communauté à cette crise a
continué à chaque semaine on voit que
beaucoup de monde qu'une des cours
encore à chaque semaine donc ça fait
extrêmement plaisir et sans plus
attendre mon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
catherine bernard j'ai écouté quelques
épisodes de votre balade dos on
s'appelle et on déjeune puis j'adore ce
merci on va tous être pertinents pis le
format est le fun c'est pas trop long
c'est sur le fly c'est pertinent c'est
vraiment un message beaucoup de fun ou
salle enregistre il aimait tellement ça
sent un peu bête écoute le podcast meti
sévèrement j'ai eu des discussions
katherine puis moi on avait eu au
téléphone tout le temps welch compter
comme équipe y compris juste enregistré
ouais c'est le fun d'avoir dit c'est pas
trop long mais c'est le fun à bron un
petit peu plus de temps dans les médias
notamment on a souvent un 5 à 7 minutes
pc tools avec des fois c'est un peu trop
court pour est surtout ceux avec un
sujet qu'on n'avait jamais pu aborder
parce que puis les deux travaillent dans
les médias ça fait un petit bout du pied
plein de sujets que sont des personnes
que jamais voulu m'engager pour en
parler c'est beaucoup trop pousser votre
avoir déterré sport où c'est comme ok
mais tu vas voir trois minutes pour en
parler comme non ça prend une heure ils
me j'avais avoir effleuré le petit bout
avec le podcast a permis par exemple
c'est quoi un sujet maintenant que tu
rêvais d'aborder puis d'en parler
puisque près celui sur la religion la
t2a on parle comment les modes
alimentaires sont un peu comme des
religions quand ça des complices et des
co leaders exactement fait que pour moi
c'est un sujet que ça faisait longtemps
que je voulais aborder puis pourtant
c'est un sujet quand même tu es je les
dis à tous les modes ou les tutsis cd
concept dont on discute beaucoup mais de
vraiment faire le parallèle avec
l'alimentation peut vraiment être c pitt
et c'est sûr que notre réalisateur andré
martineau y est vraiment bon là pour
comme tout ce qui est bon pour le
montage parce qu'il faut qu'on ait leurs
études
on évoque aussi dans nos idées mais
aussi pour ajouter des petits
échantillons sonores des choses comme ça
que moi j'adore ou des extraits outils
pour vraiment mettre en contexte
puis ce site et si on n'est ce pas
chanceux de la bourse le
on fait vraiment une belle équipe puis
puis ça pis je trouve que ça ça rendait
le sujet peut-être un petit peu plus
léger c'est d'abord des tués sont des
échantillons sonores
c'est le fun à voir votre conversation
téléphonique en début de nuit mais la
table vraiment passionné et même le soir
vous appelez le matin on essayait
assureurs dans votre vie avec des idées
nutrition c'est les deux personnages
silencieux notre podcast vous les
connaissez pas mais nos deux hommes sont
en podcast aussi j'ai changé mais ouais
si le matin c'est pas du don et relève
tous précaires pour être si ça arrive
c'est par heure du matin quand on se
perd dans quatre ans je me demande si ça
fait longtemps que par la personne des
choses l'actualité l'émission on va dire
on va dépasser d'arrêt car oui s'est
rassuré sur détail les leçons qui ont
été publiés ouais mais j'en met en page
entend ce partage est au dessus juste
article qui est sorti l'on ait cru
évident et des choses qu'on ne dit pas
non plus parce que ça va rester en dhr 2
4 1 de piment mais c'est quand au dessus
quelques personnes qu'est-ce que la dîme
iginla podhaler puis ça nous passe dans
acquis mais pourquoi s'appelle allure a
pour tête à tête à table et on devrait
faire quelque chose là-dessus pis tu
fais que ça nous paraît vraiment j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
de d'information mais de mauvaises
informations qui circulent sur la
nutrition de plus en plus on dirait que
c'est tellement difficile de mettre
d'avoir la vérité puis d'avoir ce qui
s'est d'abord juste les lip les données
exactes
maintenant s'il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup d'impressions geslin protéger
l'impression j'ai l'impression qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'impressions qui demande
qui ont pas du tout la formation pour
avoir des propos par rapport à
l'instruction qui en prennent puis qui
ans qui en parle un peu que met-on je
pense à des entraîneurs que je vois
passer sur internet qui qui eux semblent
parce qu'ils y ont déjà essayé quelque
chose on allait savoir c'est quoi la
vérité mais ça c'est un fléau
c'est ce que tu dis c'est ça c'est que
en fait pas fait déjà tout le monde
mange fait que c'est sûr que on a tous
un peu le réflexe d'avoir une opinion
par rapport à l'alimentation tout le
monde mange le pipi ya des gens qui
demandent une formation universitaire la
dame et je pense pas qu'on ait des
seules personnes sur la terre qui
connaissent l'alimentation le chevreuil
est de donner des conseils puis un peu
injustement pour revenir à l'épisode sur
l'alimentation les religions c'est
exactement ce c'est que déjà mangé c'est
culturel et social ces et motifs tout le
monde mange
puis le moindrement qu'on a vécu une
expérience explique ray guide avec
l'alimentation mais évidemment vont
vouloir convaincre comme la religion
convaincre tout le monde qui est moi ça
m'a tellement fait du bien de retrouver
la chose de manger certains aliments pas
manger certains aliments
peut-être que forcément ça va faire du
bien à tout le monde depuis pied
rapidement puis à c'est un peu ce qu'on
s'a amine ça mène des discussions je
trouve
c'est dommage parce que l'alimentation
c'est censé être rassemblé les gens je
trouve qu'il ya certains moments où
on se divise beaucoup parce que si puis
même chose avec la religion est
évidemment il ya des gens qui sont hyper
croyant qu'ils sont super voir d'esprit
puis qui vont pouvoir parler de
différentes croyances sans problème dans
le respect mais en augmentation c'est un
peu ça c'est que c'est comme si toi tu
crois qu à la même où le même modèle
alimentaire que moi mais forcément tu es
dans le tort donc on peut pas manger
ensemble si c'est qu'on est presque
rendu le mot sur ce super triste est
passé on devrait pouvoir partager nos
expériences puis se faire goûter à des
affaires sans juger l'autre c'est de
manger ou de ne pas manger certains
aliments tout cas qui n'ont pris leur
poste au moment de socialisation super
important avec régler des conflits
atteint puisque comme parler donner tes
opinions une soupe c'est vrai que si on
se met à tout manger tout seul
ben c'est une occasion compère de
discuter puis évidemment être plus
métaphorique ou sinon sens que voilà ça
c'était aussi on est en train de voir
des clivages entre les différentes
sectes alimentaire dernièrement on le
vul avec télé vegan interdits sont allés
donner des messages textes ont été des
messages c'est devenu il ya deux clans
il ya deux klapisch est vraiment pas là
pour dire ce qui est une bonne chose
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais là j'ai 2
400 train de se former parce que là il
ya un canyon qui est en train de se
former en groupe
je pense que c'est une bonne chose mais
même un canyon entre ai dit je voudrais
moi tous mes amis via ne seraient jamais
allés manifester fait que ces ya même un
canyon entre les vegans ça je trouve ça
super
parce que si comme tu es tu encore une
fois si on peut être dans la découverte
plus partagé des repas ensemble qui va
en coûter des choses c'est moi je voyage
beaucoup le fait que mon monde
ma passion dans la vie c'est de
rencontrer des gens pis c'est soit que
de manger avec les gens ça je trouve
qu'on en apprend goûter sur les sur les
autres cultures sauf moi ma façon de
manger de dire comme homme
- dans le fond j'ai peut-être pas partie
comme beaucoup en question quand on
voyage puis moi je sais ce que je trouve
qui est vraiment quelque chose de des
coûts c'est la découverte c'est toujours
bienvenu qui l'a découverte à ce fils
dans le respect dans le fond dans
l'ouverture d'esprit musique puis je
pense que manger
ça ça à tous ses côtés le sait ça ça
peut avoir tous ses côtés lobs je trouve
ça vraiment dommage d'avoir des dix plus
de clivages c'est peut-être ce que tu
manges et justice pis et c'est ce que tu
dis ça résonne beaucoup pour moi parce
que finalement je sais juste de
comprendre qu'il n'existe pas une seule
bonne façon de manger les ânes n'existe
pas donc quand tu parlais de toutes ces
personnes qui s'invente comme des cours
ou de l'alimentation puis qu'ils disent
et de même que tu dois manger ses seules
la bonne chose qu'il faut que tu manges
et compagnie ben c'est sûr que c'est
n'importe quoi parce qu'il n'existe pas
une seule passion manger parce que c'est
bien plus large que juste la science ou
juste la spiritualité ou juste la
culture s'y rassemblent tout ça et plein
d'autres aspects aussi dans le non vie
peut-être que peut-être que la f111
stretch un peu trop grand mais j'ai
l'impression que cette espèce de clivage
le transcende l'alimentation c'est
vraiment dans tout en ce moment si on a
l'impression qu'il en fait j'ai
l'impression que tout est noir ou blanc
qui ce soit en politique que ce soit en
culture que ce soit est justement en
alimentation
que ce soit dans les changements
climatiques il ya plusieurs maintenant
des groupes qui s'opposent drastiquement
l'un à l'autre puis ça créé des clivages
un homme comme se compare en
alimentation lemay de niveau sociétaires
je pense et puis peut-être que l'image
de s'asseoir puis mangé ensemble est un
image forte pour pour l'ensemble la
société en fait je pense que oui parce
que c'est georges revient encore à la au
lien avec la religion c'est comment
qu'on comment faire la meilleure façon
pour tubes et l'ignorance ou les listes
des perçu ou quoi que ce soit c'est
s'asseoir ensemble puits de secours être
apprendre apprendre à se connaître
parce que si on a six ans on n'a pas
d'amis musulmans sont un peu d'amis
juifs sont un peu d'amis guzzistes
comment comme on va juste rester avec
nous dès perçu de ce qu'est cette
religion le par rapport à ce que les
médias nous présentent par rapport à ce
qu'on voit dans les films par rapport à
ce que rite est vraiment l'image qu'on
suive
puis après quand on si on partage un
repas où son
on une discussion a finalement c'est
encore une fois ça revient beaucoup au
voyage mais je voudrais des gens de
toutes les confessions il y en a plein à
montréal
le fait qu'il ait pas compliqué qu'on
peut au besoin de voyager loin mais mais
d'avoir ces conversations le pis faire
comme au hockey dans le fonds supposent
sur outils comme revenons à
l'alimentation mais au moins je trouve
ce baye mor le c'était la lutte elle
modèle alimentaire vont parler du
mécanisme parce que c'est de ce qu'on
parle de ces temps ci mais moi je
comprends pas le molleton culte m payés
que je trouve ce don bizarre puis ça
goûte visiter la texture ses besoins b
mangeons ensemble puis ça risque d'être
moins besoin au lieu de juste observer
de loin puis de faire comme un mois y
compris suppose loin c'est ce n'est de
loin pas de juste observer de juger
selon eux on avance paul comme société
tech c'est encore une fois tant dans le
partage pendant l'ouverture d'esprit je
pense qu'elles auront au moins on peut
revendre conversation tourne important
d'avoir des conversations plus important
de d'être c'est d'être à l'aise avec le
fait de ne pas être d'accord avec tout
on a qu on devrait pas être d'accord
justement comme tu dit bernanke
il n'y a pas une façon de s'alimenter
personnes puissent mêmes pieds au canada
mais quand on regarde justement les
autres cultures mais là on est dans un
contexte complètement différent fait que
c'est sûr car encore le si on n'a
vraiment pas la vérité mais de rester
dans cette dans cette ouverture d'esprit
le je pense que c'est comme nous et la
clé c'est drôle analogie la religion de
la secte motors annonçait remarquer
j'aime bien ça a été seule la réaction
c'est ici une secte vois ta fille
convertie par ton ami exactement ce
qu'on facilite une religion une sex
pinana puis c'était possible mais
finalement justement b
on mange ensemble puis elle découvre des
nouvelles recettes parce que faire
plaisir
finalement tout le monde mange moins
bien oui dernièrement
puis je peux plus de ce qu'on voulait
parler aujourd'hui le dorian mans il ya
eu prendre ma le documentaire qui a fait
le plus parler depuis longtemps de game
challenger produit par james cameron
entre autres avec le producteur exécutif
des athlètes de haut niveau alors que la
menotte loïs hamilton qui est un
documentaire qui traite de véganisme qui
a été traîné dans la boue parfois qui
est encensé d'autrefois que dans lequel
en fait on suit combattant ultime qui
qui se blessent qui veut revenir à sa
forme donc qui s'intéresse à plusieurs
sortes d'alimentation pour finalement
tomber sur le véganisme pire c'est une
nuance tout à l'heure ça me sortent
jamais sauter au visage quand tu parlais
des militants vegan dernièrement qu'ils
sont allés chercher du rebif
puis après ce au manitoba déplace dans
plusieurs restaurants en français on a
fait la distinction entre végétalien et
vegan en anglais ya font pas
nécessairement by la forme c'est soit
plein buzz vous vegan mais je crois que
c'est important de faire la distinction
que une diète végétalienne c'est pas
nécessairement quelqu'un qui gagne qui
vont l'apprendre de garder ça transcende
l'alimentation le futur on en reparlera
peut-être tout à l'heure ça pour dire
que de game angels
ou est ce que finalement ça tourne
autour du du végétalisme dans le sport
qui vous avez fait un épisode sur ceux
de votre balade au je sais pas trop par
où on peut entreprendre la question moi
c'est un documentaire qui a une fonction
primordiale à mon avis qui est de
défaire des mythes par rapport à
l'alimentation
bernard tu parlais à tomber dans votre
balade au que tu as fait ta maîtrise sur
le lien entre la viande et la
masculinité je sais pas si c'était cela
de façon plus précis je m'intéressais
vraiment où en fait à l'orientation
sexuelle puis au comportement
alimentaire ok mais finalement c'était
comme évidemment je commençais ma
recherche avec à la fin on va dire quand
j'ai commencé à plus comprendre
grosso modo le truc le plus important
qui ressortait de ce que je comprenais
c'est que les aliments sont associés
dans notre société un genre très souvent
ne sont neutres mais il y en a beaucoup
qui vont être associés aux gens dont les
légumes les salades le tofu c'est plus
féminin pis la viande y lisait le
fast-food pile alcool se construit comme
étant plus masculin notre exception
évidemment c'est dans les aliments n'ont
aucun succès de la question sociale
compte des fabrications spéciales du
même type que si je peux pas un bout de
tissu puis si je me la tâche autour de
ma taille c'est une je sais je porte un
vêtement féminin
ici je mets georges pourquoi je mène je
ne portais quoi 1,24 fake et donc la
viande c'est très très fortement social
masculine tpiy allez pas à l'époque
savaient pas si longtemps mais quand
même
le végétarisme le végétalisme était pas
mal moins populaire il y avait même des
études qui s'intéresse à sa fille une
des barrières puis j'en parlais pas
d'enthousiasmé une des barrières ou
végétarisme et vous végétalisme chez les
hommes s'étaient justement la perception
des d'avoir trop efféminé
comme devant une semaine en centre loire
masculine tipi l'adoption de ces
comportements alimentaires donc de
manger des aliments plus mais tu vois je
trouve ça intéressant parce que je me
demande comme en fait moi je trouve ça
super intéressant de parler du
documentaire avec avec vous deux pays
tous bernard est ce que bon c'est pas ok
c'est pas comme si vous aviez arrêté de
manger de la viande depuis de game
angels mettons mais je trouve ça quand
même fascinant que c'est comme tout et
berne en toi depuis depuis la diffusion
de ce documentaire le habituellement
pour ceux des filles qui étaient créées
kilos depuis de genkai josé plein doute
ont ils cru trouver - tous les geeks -
c'est juste par rapport à juin mais en
fait je me demande si le documentaire
avait été fait par une fille athlètes
même affaire d'ego difficulté comme une
deux filles je pense dans le grinch
résonance que excuse est ce que le
documentaire ait fait autant de vagues
chez les gars sont mitigés parce que
c'était le but exact documentaire de
d'aller chercher son public cible
ah mais oui mais c'est très évident je
trouve c'est juste mais tombe ça me
faisait rêver parce que mettons tout
commence le documentaire puis dans les
cinq premières minutes qui n'est pas un
mot à une pression qu'il dit c'est juste
le goût à quel point qui est badass qui
être un bon combattant
c'est juste la force démis là dessus si
le issing dans les cinq premières
minutes d'un couteau il ya tiger qui est
moche très moche forme d'aidé mais ici
aussi des tissus et puis juste pour hook
et le mall farine qui fait tellement
reconnais là dedans tu intéressant puis
après sa part une version puis on dit
que après si on voit les enfants au pis
tous qui plus est environnement pile
touche à sa fin regardez pas la fin mais
tout ce qui est bien mal leur mais c'est
au début pour vraiment qu'ils se sentent
concernés par cette audience mais au
final c'est que je trouve plus je le dis
dans notre
l'ado mais ce que je trouve vraiment
intéressant c'est de défaire cette
espèce de mythe que pour faire du sport
de haut niveau il faut inévitablement
manger de la viande montre est également
le monde ne se cherche trouve c'est pour
moi c'est vraiment le point le plus fort
un documentaire c'est de briser aussi de
briser l'image que un vrai homme peut
manger vg ouais même si évidemment à la
base c'est sûr que je déplore le fait
d'utiliser des modèles de masques d'une
tique son corps y participer et on
reparle de gladiateurs ouais bon pied
l'homme le plus fort au monde et
athlétique en fonction les petits
muscles pour tout qu'est-ce que dans nos
têtes on considère comme étant le plus
possible il s'est vu demander des
stéréotypes qui sont quand même assez
toxique parce que la majorité des gars
on n'adhère pas assez on va jamais
l'atteindre mais de l'autre côté
mais justement ils ont utilisé ces
stéréotypes l'eau pour aller à linverse
puis brisé un autre mythe qui brident le
fait que tu peux être un vrai homme qui
manger autre chose que juste d'avions
depuis six ans que c'est important que
ça soit fait aussi ça peut paraître
n'existe que peu de gens qui vont
écouter puis vendu à la commune genre
qu'ils ont peur de manger de la viande
légaux ou non un même sens ça rend pas
compte en arrière il ya une pression
sociale que le feu genre sortie publique
mais c'est simple je passe une défense
du film c'est que c'est pas vu un film
qui consommaient juste par les
convertissent est un film justement qui
veut être toi tu vois si quelqu'un ose t
du du duo igor est carnivore
voilà qui je vais donner une chance
parce que c'est ce que je pense c'est un
stratagème d'utiliser justement des
stéréotypes les trucs brava mainstream
puis de faire un film vraiment
meanstream mais pour par la barre parler
d'un message qui - mini trépied solide
de prêcheurs face à l'ab
mais c'est vraiment d'aller à mi chemin
c'est vraiment allé comme on veut
trouver une façon de rendre de passer le
message qui va la fin d'un bien plus
large mais doute de gens parce que s'il
n'y était pas allé aussi caricatural
dans ces exemples peut-être que il est
bas moins de gens qui a raccroché pitt
et moi j'ai déjà en béton c'est mon
coloc et un bon mangeur de viande qui
est vu sous mon ami tim mon ami marc
antoine qui est comme la postérité mais
c'est ma robe de viande de veau au jam
qui m'a ému ce clip ce trip ici il
m'écrit be1 et toutes des p t j ai un
petit sac du mieux c'est a commencé puis
le voyait qui est injectée se plaindre
et que c'est la fontaine de jouvence le
citoyen ouvre la possibilité
ouais ouais c'est vraiment ça ou la
possibilité assez possible de faire ce
que rien qu'ils sont pauvres et pc mais
ça c'est bon mais comme elle ne sera
peut-être pas dire le film vaut quand
même plus loin et puis aman i khas loin
ses amarres et c'est quasiment 10 puis
on y reviendra de tickets est ici
vraiment dit littéralement et ni animaux
produits ce que tu pourrais que c'était
à manger sont mauvais rotois pivot
facile parce que la dépendance
en fait il ya plusieurs moments forts
dans le film qui peuvent frapper
l'imaginaire si vous n'en avez pas dans
votre podcast la section sur le simple
la clarté du centre après avoir mangé un
but rittaud avec la viande plus
lentement burritos sans viande ou est-ce
que le synthé beaucoup plus clair quand
on mange un but rittaud sans viande
ce que vous disiez en votre podcast on
peut la borella tulle qui était de dire
que peu importe de ton que si tu manges
de quoi sans viande mais rempli de gros
bon sens va malgré tout à être pas clair
à ce point le puits que si c'était juste
pas montré que la nuance et ai pas dit
mais est ce que quelque chose qui est
dit là dessus parce que le guilly les
avocats dans son dans son bus rideau qui
dit c'est que le gros des avocats ça va
pas quatre pour brouiller toussaint puis
maintenant ce serait ça c'est bon
ok elle et qu'elle est là sur quelle
pièce condense par rapport à ça parce
qu'on sait que les produits d'origine
allemand la viande ondes du raz
l'intérieur de gros qui se retrouvent
pas gras trans entre autres dans la
viande rouge c'est pas des grottes bcg
des graisses saturées en grande majorité
il ya des gras trans dans la vie en
groupe e devant de gras trans mais c'est
pas les mêmes gras trans industrielle
que ceux qui se disent dans leur super
retraite qui avait pas le même quand
même pas tout à fait vrai successeur
andry hakim et ont mangé la viande le
saint plus brouillés si comme tu le vois
aller nul c'est impressionnant mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça tu
vraiment il a fait sur la santé ça tu
vraiment c'est aussi ce que ces jarres
de grock s'accumulent dans les artères
c'est ce que parce que c'est là qu'ils
s'en vont en montrant seul c'est un
montrant que ces gros là c'est ça qui
vient boucher ses artères
sur quelle pièce conte ans parce qu'on
sait on seulement occupent la viande
rouge somme toute est liée aux maladies
cardiaques maladies vénériennes fake qui
j'imagine que ça tire un peu de ce fait
que je vous laisse vous laisse la table
on veut aller aux ignorants que nous
retournons en arrière un peu de la vie
de cette question là premièrement c'est
quoi cette expérience le qui font ces
trois gars leur faut manger quelque
chose ils prennent leur sens ils sont
ils maintenant la centrifugeuse
il regarde la clarté de leur sang après
que ce soit par senna centrifugeuses la
leur mais reprennent les mêmes trois
gaillards donne quelque chose à manger
mais leur sont la centrifugeuse brigade
puis le repas vg leur sang il y ait plus
que la com et puis catherine je
reprendrai des propos de notre podcast
ça fait de la crise tibbon télé parce
que ces gens ont beau dieu sait comme
savidan
en corse la chose la plus importante là
où il en est un qui sait un beau simple
autres 5 pas beau ça selon ce qu'on
semble moody's la réalité c'est que 1 3
personnes ce n'est pas une expérience
scientifique très loin de là ça ne vaut
rien céder il même même s'il avait fait
100 personnes ça serait pas mieux parce
que c'est pas contrôler le stand rex
espérant centimes et donc savourer c'est
un vrai argument donc très souvent dans
les documentaires on voit cela ils font
des expériences comme ça où des petites
comme la plus insistante plus qu'une
expérience qui a l'air d'être un
argument mais c'est pas un vrai argument
qu'on peut pas prendre ça aussi c'est un
on rajoute suis comme un petit dégoûte
supplémentaire de l'argumentaire non
après ce lot question c'est qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
ils ont comprend pas qu'il ne
l'expliquent pas qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
donc c'est juste une image qui déjà là
je me dis comme la majorité des gens qui
l'écoutent n'ont pas de formation en
sciences ou en santé donc qu'on prenne
pas plus que ça veut dire
le seul message qu'on aurait pressensé
où c'est dangereux lexus à nos problèmes
il autre chose aussi c'est que le ski
regardait c'est justement donc le gaza
qui étaient dans leur sens il ya plein
de facteurs qui peuvent l'influencer
-notamment bon il y avait peut-être des
avocats mais probablement je ne suis pas
con le pollack hall d'accueil
qu'est-ce qui se retrouvaient dans leurs
produits on sait pas mais si tu mange
des aliments gras mais vg tu vas voir
aussi dégradantes on sent donc c'est pas
juste en mangeant de la viande que
soudain monta du grain dans ton sens
vite c'est normal comment est aussi
plein de facteurs et ceci en plus
d'enlever le côté de ça se peut très
bien que si pauvres et ceux comme comme
maire comme téléspectateur c'est hyper
important de garder sans tête ne pas
rêver avoir inventé ça on ne sait pas
qui sont des menteurs maintenant c'est
sûr que ça peut arriver pieds tellement
d'autres données que devra traiter leurs
regards dans leur peau mais qu'est ce
que mangent les ajournés qu'est ce qui
est plus il ya tellement d'autres
juridique pour entrer dans ligne de caen
- cissé pitié c'est sûr que sont là d'un
point de vue c'est scientifique est
resté sous ses connu le par exemple télé
les fibres par exemple dans les ligues
mineures
ben oui ça va aider le niveau du taux de
cholestérol sanguin dans
légumes dans l'est dans les végétaux ça
va aider au niveau du tout que ses
récents gains se situe pas connu le
métier c'est tellement moins facile à
illustrer l'expérience qui ont fait le
que c'est mais pourtant l'argumentaire
de dire comme ben je vais manger
justement ce chat risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires va augmenter mon mais
mon apport en végétaux l'ex assauts des
légumes des légumineuses des noirs
peuvent peu importe pour aider à
diminuer mon tout les stérols sanguin ça
marche le 6 mai c'est comme un petit
conseil nutritionnel qui comme si c'est
moins fun que de voir des fioles de sang
avec mes oublis s'était fixé fait que
ses côtés entre ces îles il aurait pu
passer par la vraie information mais
c'est moins comme les flashs simon's
town depuis qu'elle est quelle est la
vraie information par rapport à la
relation entre la viande puis le
cholestérol la viande puis les maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est qu'elle est
qu'elle est là la science derrière ce
parce qu'on en entend parler mais quel
est réellement les faire dans cette
histoire le nom parce que je me lance la
balle parce qu'on en parle souvent
des maladies cardiovasculaires comme
étant est réducteur
ensuite c'est à quoi plusieurs répondent
que ce qui est héréditaire c'est surtout
les comportements nutritionnels les
comportements alimentaires et sévirait
dans le mode de vie exact puisque une
part vraiment plus minime que ce qu'on
croit qui est héréditaire dans cette
histoire le fait que le poète qu en est
il de la relation entre la viande et les
maladies cardiovasculaires en vrai
j'aurais le goût mais j'irai pas trop
long au loin ou plutôt de se reprendre
et je sais pas mais parce qu'il ya une
chose que j'ai mais je vais rester sur
ta question parce que je rêve ou
l'alimentation c'est vraiment plus large
que juste les aliments qui ment et la
santé c'est beaucoup plus large que les
aliments qui ment je suis tout à fait on
on y reviendra je pense que c'est
vraiment important
si tu regarde juste la viande oui c'est
vrai la consommation élevée de viande
rouge est associée à une augmentation
des maladies cardiovasculaires est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faut que tu
élimines la viande rouge pour limiter
ces risques pas du tout et évidemment
c'est que la viande rouge c'est ça c'est
que c'est pas la seule chose et les
viandes transformées aussi présidence
avec mis ensemble dans les études faites
tomber qu'une ton jambon pittet sur des
péronistes et pogo meir souvent si grand
marais la même catégorie dans les études
des étudiants sommes avec la viande le
un steak haché avec rien te comprends
mais on s'entend que c'est pas la même
qualité alimentaire non plus mais dans
les études des fois ça disparaît cette
distinction là parce qu'on a juste
demandé aux gens qu'est ce qu'on
mangeait comme une viande ont mangé le
groupe i le le poteau 30 ans en mai
entre donc il ya une distinction très
importante à faire sa transformation
s'excusera bordés plus tard mais y au
niveau de l'alimentation s'est aussi
beaucoup plus large mais il reste qu on
sait manger
vge ou du moins manger plus de végétaux
oui s'est associé à des moins de risque
de maladie cardiovasculaire moins de
cancers c'est bien démontré ne s'est pas
controversé la sens nous le dit c'est
pour ça que je dirais même le guide
alimentaire canadien c'est ce qu'il m'a
dit que la majorité notre assiette
devrait être constituée de fruits de
légumes de légumineuses degré entier
dont le regard est rien controversé là
dedans c'est vrai là où mon genre je
critique un peu plus de documentaires
c'est un peu comme s'ils disaient ce
qu'ils nous disaient si tu manges un
seul était foutu même pas de viande
largement celle et les autres c'est le
on dirait quelqu'un c'est mou mou
j'avais si j'avais accepté sur tille le
fait que la viande rouge
clairement il faut diminuer de
consommation en général puis une
consommation excessive augmente les
risques de cancer du côlon entre autres
et autres malaisie ce cas mais le
factice ou imagine que c'est un conseil
senti que vous donnez souvent le
diminuer sa consommation de viande rouge
oui ou au contre la façon négative de 10
mg en joignant manger la façon positive
c'est une engeance de végétaux pic en
marge des légumineuses des fruits des
légumes des craintes et où des recettes
pour les cuisiner pilote est justement
comme ces tensions bon ok j'ai le 10 mai
avec l'union ainsi comme en une ce
converti conversation à 3,2 justement de
philosophie de comment passer les
messages en justement comme ces temps ci
je pense de plus en plus le pile sur
tous les deux est un bon abdallah met à
me faire réfléchir mais c'est vraiment
aller plus sur le positif
un but vraiment vraiment plus parler
d'eux waouh c'est tellement bon
cuisinier d'une future gamme a6 est
bonne puis j'ai comme plus le goût
d'aller vers ce mec mais question à ma
question est la vie la viande rouge
ok mais est ce qu'ils aiment et on vous
encourage à riez les gens à diminuer la
consommation de lait de produit animal à
cluj le plus largement que la viande
rouge
c'est ce qui est impossible à dire parce
que chaque personne est différente et je
peux potes
en fait non de façon générale la façon
courte
la réponse courte sinon j'encouragerai
paul et jean nécessairement a diminué
d'un point de vue de leur santé je suis
tout ce que je vous passe
ouais la rue leur est évidemment pas
nécessairement encore une fois c'est une
dimanche 8 peuvent par jour oui j'adore
de diminuer comprend donc chaque
personne est différente c'est pour ça
que c'est impossible de lancer des
messages globaux comme ça le point avec
la viande rouge et que c'est avec les
statistiques de consommation on sait que
la majorité des gens technos a dit
nuit mais consomme trop de viande rouge
en général donc c'est facile de dire ce
serait mieux d'en consommer moins de
l'éliminer non y'a bonne les études
montrent pas qu'il faut absolument
éliminer des produits qui viennent des
animaux si tu vas être en santé
est-ce que du point de vue scientifique
le film fait des erreurs flagrantes dans
le sens que oui il ya plein de choses
que j'avais entendu puisque là on l'a
même déjà discuté au podcast est ok
c'est comme ça ça fonctionne exemple les
protéines qui une combinaison d'acides
aminés de ce que je comprends dans la
viande assez complète dans les végétaux
à ses partiels devraient manger très
variés en tvg tôt pour avoir une
protéine qui est complète oui c'est
toujours comme ça que j'avais comme
convenu su bluffer me dis oh bah ce que
nous avons entendu ces pauvres et puis
en fait toutes les protéines note
d'entrée végétaux sont complètement
c'est que la vérité là dedans ouais mais
en fait cessé
c'est vrai que les protéines végétales
sont incomplètes que mais on a souvent
dit attention le parce que si vous
mangez des légumes ne soit absolument
manger des céréales en même temps ou des
noix ou c'est parce que sinon leur aide
vraiment à vous allez manquer de
protéines ça sera pas équilibré du tout
et mais finalement on se rend compte que
c'est on va pas juste manger des légumes
noces dans notre journée c'est sûr qu'on
va manger des séries a c'est sûr qu'on
va probablement probablement manger des
noix ou des grandes choses comme ça et
ça vaut se compléter sans problème c'est
comme je voudrais des végétariens et
végétaliens qui sont comment grande
carence de protéines non m est un
chrétien qui est annoncé ça c'est
vraiment qui justement c'est encore une
fois ça vient après que la question de
la viande ou là que toutes ces avancées
que souvent on va regarder les aliments
on regarde juste l'aliment tout seul
l'organe a dans ses aliments légers du
cholestérol pilote l acide aminé pluie
on n'a pas pu tout ça puis dans les
dernières des sinistrés comme cela notre
sens est de décortiquer des aliments
dans leurs nutriments puis de comme
commencé à analyser ça ça marche pas
vous regarder vraiment de façon plus
large puis avec les végétaux en fait
avec les sources de protéines végétales
légumineuses les végétariens pas plus de
protéines que les hommes niveau même que
même que le film avance vraiment un
point dans le film qui un mangeur de
viande moyens autant de protéines très
grande pompe par jour en moyenne et un
vegan le temple c'est comme deux fois
plus si le cmj convaincu moi je suis
convaincu qu'on comprend pas toutes les
protéines qu'on a besoin
les végétaux indiqué que les vegan en
cause un bowling deux fois plus margées
la viande montrer que j'ai dit mais si
tu es vraiment nécessaire de savoir
comment il faut toujours en avoir plus
de l'eau chez maman de compétition
protéines mais en fait pis je reviens
sur ce que tu disais bernanke s'est par
rapport à ces focaliser sur comme un
nutriment très très précis ou quoi que
ce soit mais c'est un peu ça aussi le
problème c'est que ce conte ce qu'on lit
pour revenait vraiment au début de la
conversation
ce qu on lit souvent dans les médias par
rapport à l'alimentation par rapport à
certaines études
c'est justement on étudie des nutriments
on étudie des désagréments des fois des
groupes d'alimenter viande rouge est
bien de transformer ce pas tout à fait
la même affaire donc on étudie des trucs
très très ciblé parce qu'on veut avoir
un résultat le plus précis possible
puis après ça nous on interprète nous le
commun des mortels on interprète ce dans
notre alimentation de tous les jours
mais tiéné on vit pendant ce laboratoire
là si on vit pas au modèle d'étude si on
a justement on va manger d'autres
aliments avec son effectif de dire comme
bompard prenons la viande rouge c'est
qu'ils mangent de la viande rouge une
fois de temps en temps mais la majorité
de ton alimentation c'est des végétaux
sérieux pauvres et manquent 13 pour
toile
d après tu peux choisir de ne pas en
manger du tout la viande c'est bien
correct aussi métissé comme cette espèce
de ces deux dates de prendre toujours
l'espèce de peau de recul pour dire
comme acquis globalement c'est quoi
cette affaire loti pour deux c'est pia
pression foulé d'apprêter selon notre
contexte note notre religion selon la
culture selon neutre notre environnement
dans quel environnement ovi est ce que
c'est accessible ou non c'est bon
c'est toutes les questions qui sont
pertinentes pics sont valables en fait
le temps choisi ou non de manger
certainement puits d'où l'intérêt
d'avoir des études qui vont regarder des
grands groupes de populations qui vont
regarder bella au final quand on regarde
tout qu'est ce qu'ils mangent donc on
considère leur mode de vie
non parce que tu regardes des gens dans
la vraie vie qu'est ce ça nous donne
comme résultat dont i ce qu'on voit
c'est que les végétariens ont peu plus
de 40 que les amis vont donc à quai au
port le corps y est capable d'aller
chercher tous les acides aminés dont il
a besoin
sans que les gens aient besoin d'y
réfléchir nécessairement donc ça nous
donne cette confiance là de dire capoter
pas avec les protéines
d'autant plus que justement on capote
tout le monde j'en ressens le premier
protège sa montre en plus plus plus
pourquoi c'est quoi une limite pas or
qu'on peut ingérer je pense à des pleins
de plaine à faire mais si j'oserais même
un athlète le quéau même d'aider des
besoins plus élevé que la moyenne des
gens sédentaires mais il ya une limite
si tu peux pas dire je veux seulement je
prends des chèques toute la journée le
tube je vois comment magasiner soit pour
eux mon entraînement de demain c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche moins bien quand
je j'ai nagé pendant 20 ans puis j'ai
fait quand joe niveau afin d'acquérir la
avec les rouge et or j'étais allé voir
une nutritionniste qui qui m'avait dit
on avait pris c'est mon poids puis monte
aux deux groupes y en avait 10 ans oat
26 grammes de protéines comme après ton
entraînement le tout ceci gaspiller ça
pue à rien une limite soit d'échec que
tu prends un scoop à george sand 12 g
ceci est pour le piscénois bataille que
c'est un bel hommage de ses 13 ans marc
levy c'est un endroit parce que les deux
on est comme je te suit de façon très
diplomatique également écrit mais c'est
parce que on s'est tellement fait poser
de questions
de hockey comme une gamme de produits ce
que je peut absorber à l'heure si je
fait l europe telle affaire il avait
piqué au final
pis son deuxième livre il a tué mon
deuxième essai genre ça crie mais mon
business c'est comme arrêtons de parler
de crise et on n'est pas radio c'est
sensé sans que justement c'est des trucs
au fur et à mesure me mets à évacuer de
mon esprit page me dit de toute façon
c'est pas de cette façon dont j'ai envie
c'est vraiment la microgestion exact qui
amène qui mettrait ce qui amène vraiment
du très dans la vie des gens qui souvent
est inutile comme avec le cas des
protéines
quand on regarde les études 98 % des
québécois mangent suffisamment ou trop
de protéines
donc ce n'est vraiment pas une crème à
voir mais tout le monde capote qui
pensent que doivent à manger plus mais
si possible que les études nous manque
c'est drôle parce que quand on passe
d'une tension directement tout d'un coup
s'imaginent qu'ils athlètes de haut
niveau dans sa cellule à laquelle les
louis tu vas avoir un
souvent même temps des plans
alimentaires parce que c'est des
machines
oui le selor c'est leur vie c'est leur
métier que le record soit au top top des
fois la liga ni d'une seconde mais ils
vont tout faire pour gagner à l'avancé
comme c'est trop
et pour 0 5 ans toutes fermées sauf que
c'est dans la ville
si à un moment donné il ya une mode sur
le jus de betterave et au début 2012 et
elle a parlé d' être mais là pas dans le
film il ya parlé également donné puis
oui c'est vrai chez les athlètes de haut
niveau le jus de betterave semble
augmenter les performances mais comme
vraiment le intense et c'est possible
aussi
mais sauf qu'ils vont gagner 1 % 10 %
est-ce qui va courir 5 km le pour le fun
3d sera ça coûte vraiment cher en
betteraves dans les détails seuls ces
mêmes élèves par le monde qui nous
écoute votre oncle qui fait des arrêts
de même lui devrait sans qui sait même
pas ce que l'on est et on parle même pas
de techint qu'on parle 2.5 secondes
c'est un nom c'est le 0,0001 % de la
population celle et justement les
maillots police les olympiens de fine
pointe des triathlètes qu'ils font pour
le plaisir ou juste parce que sont eux
ça leur fait important parce que les
entrepreneurs tout tout ce monde le
c'est pas grave qui en même temps je me
posais vous êtes mieux vous devriez pas
faire ça pas du tout si ça vous fait
triper de cinq pensent de moi quelqu'un
qui se dit moi la sentence
je t'ai pas athlètes mais je veux
vraiment performer beaucoup ça me fait
rire c'est mon passe temps une bichromie
il s'entraîne vraiment beaucoup pilot
son alimentation il veut vraiment la
changer puis est prêt à faire comme si
qu'ils voient plus comme un ange marie
j'sais pas quoi tu t'amuses là dedans
gopher
c'est parfait je te conseille bien cela
va du nutritionniste pour qu'elle était
là dedans mais vas-y amuse toi mais
c'est quand au contraire attendant
l'heure le dark side of the
que là ça devient comme obsessif
restrictif que tu te coupent des gens
parce que ces gens non non non ma charge
j'ai mon plan tout ça c'est là que les
dangers arrive c'est une des facettes de
l'alimentation dont on a très peu parlé
quand on voit toujours le corps comme
une machine qu'on doit rentrer les bons
nutriments à l'intérieur ou qu'on peut
programmer mais je trouve que par
rapport aux sports le téléthon je peux
moi je pense moi je fais du vélo de
route c'est comme en sport nautique qui
je pourrai elle est justement le sait
consulter mes amis qui sont spécialistes
en nutrition sportive
je préfère mais c'est de dire comme
haïti comme le quand je fais des longues
randonnées je mangeais tête de la force
par performant mais tu mets ton moi je
pense que dans le sport comme dans
l'alimentation faut s'écouter
c'est parce que mettons moi j'ai fait
des voyages des vélos je te demande
toujours à cuba une semaine de mai je
fais du vélo avec d'autres mondes il ôte
tout at-elle j'ai l'hôtel j'ai l'heure
même où je prends mon chez moi je prends
un gel des gens apprennent une demi
heure je trouve ça dégueulasse à
anticosti qui c'est comme ça coûte super
cher mouche comme ça c'est comme
pertinente et puis c'est la même affaire
un alimentation et il est super aliments
la petite botte de chez pas trop se met
dans ton avant ça coûte une fortune
ça change rien c'est comme du faux hamon
j'ai fait le marathon de québec cet été
j'ai couru avec des jeux ben may nord
juste les juges moi je me suis déjà fait
les chips à fanta besoin de sucre
pourrait même angers au dessus des
ménages ne tremblait mais ce bref c'est
ça c'est comme manger
qu'est ce qui fonctionne pour toi qu'est
ce que dit qu'est ce que tu es manger
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce qui te
fais du vélo mais ça se peut que cette
journée là ça roule moins vite parce que
chute squatter comme c'est on est
vraiment dans une culture de performance
puis à tous les niveaux comme faut
performer dans l'assiette faut performer
peu importe le sport qu'on fait faux
console meilleur la dampierre tout les
jour peu importe de mieux dormir ou tout
autre bien dormi dix ans comme cette
espèce aussi je trouve que c'est une
source de stress quand même important
parce que c'est après ça on fait du
sport avec des gens dans notre entourage
on se compare si tu sais tu tu manges
d'une certaine façon plus comme matsui
mèche de tu manges et soutenu me tâte
poudre ne s'est pas trop mal lotis comme
en tout cas je pense que j'ai trempé
dont 24 par lé dégel puisque je pense
que si ce genre de produit vivre
d'exemples de produits qui sont vraiment
bien marketé excessivement bien
l'enquêté mais c'est plus efficace qui
est manger une banane soit csokas et
meilleur au goût de banane au maire de
la plupart des produits que tu achète
souvent tu peux te faire tu peux t'en
faire tout en même temps j'étais pas mal
moins cher le dire lesquels qui va
comparer à quoi c'est pas ma spécialité
puis récemment débarqué là dedans vous
inviterez mai mais c'est ça sauf que il
reste que je pense que souvent semé
beaucoup trop de pression là-dessus si
on veut vraiment aller vers des
performances puis le documentaire qui
joue beaucoup là dessus aussi de la
performance puis que si tu manges les
gîtes voit comme au mont 2 ça va être
fou ce qu'ils veulent mais la réalité
c'est que la majorité des gens ont tant
besoin de performances et aussi la façon
de la société nous dit quinn pistons
c'est ce qu'on vise mais prenez un recul
plus juste est acquis en plus je
souhaite pour la forme
parce que si tu te fais pas pour le fun
autant dans l'alimentation que le sport
ou le réseau ta vie ça va amener des
conséquences négatives
au final pour ta santé si tu fais juste
en disant north pour ma santé que je
fais pipe à me donner ça va t'amener des
conséquences négatives aussi pour ta
santé mais mental cette fois ci c'est
d'avoir un autre débat mais justement t
on parler de désinformation dépit de
mauvaises informations qui circulent
mais je pense qu'il sait pas vraiment
quand on pourrait en parler pendant
longtemps mais le le marketing derrière
la nutrition petit je pense que ça
contribue beaucoup à mêler les gens le
ticket de besoins des parts aliments
probiotiques 206 d'avec sauter bcc
compagnie blais qui me pose pendant
leurs produits dans le fond on
absolument puis en fait je seek bernard
est très content qu'on côtoie être
content qu'on aille le met ses dents en
alimentation bio c'est pour faire un
lien avec le documentaire
j'adore parce que on pense par
télépathie avec les élémentaires
évidemment souvent on nous parle de ça
on va nous présenter des des aliments
vegan de transformer ça c'est un truc
aussi que ce sujet dans ton nom oui mais
si cette épice et ses com mais ceci est
un autre point que je trouve dommage
parce qu'effectivement manger plus de
végétaux et yorker juste des avantages
du point de vue de santé d'environnement
de ce mail justement le l'industrie
s'est accaparé de ce marché là parce que
ça pogne points puis quand on inscrit
vega nous points de base sur un produit
souvent de recettes ou quoi que ce soit
ça comme tout le monde capote c'est que
l'on nous vend des produits weygand mais
qui finalement ou compte le contenu le
vraiment la qualité de l'aliment ce
poteau puis justement pour revenir ton
parler de maladies cardiovasculaires
plutôt long commence à regarder la
bernache pense avait lu des études
comme quoi justement sur l'histoire des
répercussions négatives
c'est de dire comment qui si je mange si
je mange beaucoup de viande beaucoup de
viandes transformées
peut-être que mon alimentation ou mon
mode de vie est pas parfait puis oui ça
augmente mon risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires mais lorsqu'on se rend
compte c'est que oui l'alimentation
vegan ou du moins végétarienne plein
plein plein davantage au niveau de la
santé cardiovasculaire mais si la
qualité de ton alimentation végétalienne
est majoritairement composé les
malheureux transformer l'eau au niveau
de la santé globale pas parfait c'est
non seulement topo les bénéfices mais
même ça semble augmenter
il risque une maladie cardiovasculaire
ou de diabète notamment mes skis
aucunement surprenant pour l'importer la
fille qu'il y des études sur la
transformation alimentaire et les
aliments transformés parti capable de
lire une fiche de val en outre été aussi
l'insee oui nobel doivent bien
comprendre d'autres choses
si généralement moi ce que je conseille
plus bas ainsi évidemment d'acheter ce
qui est pas d'emballage de manière
générale mais son seul emballage de
regarder la liste des ingrédients c'est
plus le petit va avoir de l'information
sur c'est quoi les ingrédients
l'intérieur mais on a beaucoup d'études
sur les aliments ultra transformer donc
sont des produits de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui contiennent peuvent
revendre aliments frais et et de fruits
de légumes frais de
viande ou de 9 u mais beaucoup plus de
sucre de gras de sel d'additifs de
colorants sur les gens qui en mangent
beaucoup s'est associé à plein de
problèmes de santé
mais là on se retrouve avec la même
chose actuellement végétalien genre les
boues les imitations de viande hyper
réel que ces délices d'un grisons
extrêmement longue mais c'est à ceci
évidemment pas ce produit spécifiquement
mais ce qu'on se rend compte que les
gens qui mangent une alimentation notre
attention est végétalienne augmente le
risque de maladies
y a pas un seul mot dans le documentaire
qui en parle parce qu'ils pour faire le
lien avec quand il disait de le
marketing
ben je ne sais pas j'accuse personnes
mais parmi les personnes qui font le
documentaire si tu sais tu jim termine
quand même ça ça à qui on une compagnie
de protéines de poids donc qu'ils
adhèrent à produire les produits le
transformer donc ça peut allumer lumière
dans nos têtes de noeud fait une raison
pour laquelle on nous parle jamais du
fait que manger ultra transformé ça peut
avoir des effets néfastes sur la santé
j'ai trop qu'hubert loyalistes après
trois choses par rapport à ceux dans le
documentaire justement mais une chose
qui est qui qui qui est drôle en fait il
faudrait que 0,8 et là dessus une fois
un médecin qui dit qu'au foot rouergue
rodez mais apporte très vite la pression
n'a pas pu aller mais il ya une fois le
mot foot qui dit mais sinon on n'a pas
le rappeur puis si l'expérience puisse
on en reparlera parce que c'est comique
expérience sur les élections des bleus
durant la nuit ici qu'il faut manger
la première fois en force un burrito thé
avec avec david ans d'après ce avec des
plutôt que ça soit d'aider des aliments
frais c'est des remplaçants dans la
fosse viande poulet frit boeuf tout ce
pipe en manif une expérience qui fait
aussi avec une boulette de burgers
stelvio me versus nourrit boulet depuis
le haut ma gueule des effets mais ça
sonne louche parce que c'est des
aliments transformés
même ça a été des haricots faudrait que
certaines logent comète comme toi qui as
que soudainement dimanche darricau qui
peignent jour leur mettre des belles
direction la turque ont embarqué dans
cette histoire là moi j'étais aux
costauds parce qu'on a dit on a des
plats surgelés vegan puis le nombre de
personnes qui sont venus me parler de
cette scène là que lors du chemin vert
regarder ce que leurs maris avaient
regardé ce fils lui avait demandé de vue
légal
les populations de la bouffe vegas la
nouvelle pilule bleue mais se sait la
chose qu'on m'a parlé le plus steve et
puis dans le documentaire il mentionne
dissipe pas du tout une étude clinique
c'est pas du tout qu'est ce qui est
scientifique c'est juste quelque chose
qu'on observe c'est ça il mentionne au
moins un pour être fait ils disent c'est
ça qui épicent mais c'est la chose puis
se sert on reviendra sur tout les points
qu'on abhorre je prends des notes mental
de 80 aucun confrères l'espèce de rap
pop par rapport au documentaire parce
qu'encore une fois j'ai l'impression
qu'on qu'on le traîne un peu dans bout
alors que j'ai l'impression qu'il y
aurait un impact sur toute positif
surtout sur la planète lemay continent
avec l'histoire des directions de mots
c'est la chose qu'on va parler le plus
vraiment mais tu vois même si je ne sais
pas qui de disgrâce et ça ça vaut pas
grand chose et expérience
la maladie qui montrera pas quelque
chose en disant non mais ce cas ça veut
rien dire ce que je te montre montré
pareil parce que c'est utilise quand
même comme un argument il dit
il dit mais trente secondes avant 10 et
une augmentation de 500% la fréquence
des érections
[Musique]
donc moi parce que ça c'est une autre
affaire qui me go sera plus observée
avec la masculinité
évidemment tu part de masculinité est
les érections pylônes cynisme c'est
comme la seule façon se trouvait
convaincre les gueux de changer leur
ville c'est de leur dire qu'ils vont
avoir des belles direction pick and go
sam gosses vraiment qui c'est souvent en
santé publique souvent on utilise ce
même avec la cigarette
un des arguments c'est comme attention
de votre impuissance sur la cigarette
qui comme qui est sa marche qui met
quelque chose quand même qui me gossin
plus que c'est quand on réduit toujours
les gars comme adultes et on va te
convaincre que c'est bon pour ta santé
puis la seule chose qu'on pointe
quasiment c'est ça mon magasin pulsât
amène cette image là que c'est la seule
chose importante quand tu es un gars
mais encore une fois une expérience ça
veut rien dire puis même saveur des
haricots frais l'axé vais manger peu
importe c'est quoi ces trois personnes
je peux pas utiliser cela comme un
argument ce qui moi m'intéresserait là
ça serait quelque chose allait voir
s'ils utilisent études scientifiques qui
montrent que si tu manges v g2 plus
direction nocturne gens plus ce genre à
jeter sa caisse affecté non
effectivement fait ctif mais ça amène
une belle image ça fait au mic god je
veux aller manger
l'ips la thg arrêté d'acheter des
activités depuis déjà manger léger en
même temps au final c'est bien gras que
les gens mangent végéter oui c'est ça on
ira à saint quentinois
restons sur le documentaire avant
d'élargir un petit peu la question moi
l'impression que le documentaire me
donnait sextet sommes toutes basées sur
des faits parce que les études sont
cités on a les références tout le temps
chaque fois qu'il disait quelque chose
on a une référence après ça en écoutant
justement le podcast de logan avec jane
wilkes qui le combattent en lui et s'il
lui arrive là avec des bacs et par des
spécialistes qui ont qu'ils ont envoyé
un peu comme en fait john logan il
voulait pas recevoir des spécialistes
nécessairement il voulait recevoir lui
voulait pas recevoir son docteur who et
où son nutritionniste le fait que lui
arrive là avec toutes ces faits prêt à
prendre chacun des faits dans le film
pour le démontrer oui parce que juste
pour mettre en contexte c'est que
l'épisode de jogging il fait un épisode
avec chris chris turquie vraiment le jeu
de m'entraîner le documentaire dans la
boule puis le il fait un deuxième
documentaire avec le précieux et jay-z
l'explosion comme une conversation entre
au pis c'est vrai et james est super
bien préparés puis défend très très bien
son fils tout ce qu'ils ont le temps
d'aborder dans le pot casse même si
laborieux à écouter celle enclenchée en
se les est troisième mais tous qui tous
qui parlait dans le podcast et réussi à
défendre son point - qui sont tout moi
je sais que j'ai pas la fête pas
l'esprit critique par rapport à ces
choses là mais ça m'apparaît comme étant
des vraies informations
oui me trompe mais pauvreté manger leur
masse le l'esprit critique mais je
trouvais que il y défend des super bien
sont pointés justement par rapport à la
qualité des protéines ou par rapport à
nous
ces choses là ils y habitent et après
certains points que c'est justement le
par rapport à la qualité des études ou
et wayne simmonds ces choses leur très
bon limite on s'en fout un peu le chemin
est encore l'argument de faire un bon
show final impliquant excès valable auto
droit de loi de faire un bon choix mais
mais mais en fait c'est ça tu sais
vraiment de 2 le message le message
reste le même le message c'est que c'est
possible
walt mégane fils de faire du sport de
haut niveau puis de très bien performer
puis on n'a pas besoin justement de ces
comme je t'aime en cross-country
décortiquait des trucs qui comme ok
ouais mais l'alimentation de l'homme
fort c'est pas parfait parce qu'ils
mangent plainte et bois plein de
produits avec des protéines y mange les
effraie tout un bon truc ce ou sertis
d'autres personnages où il y avait
vraiment analyse chaque personnage mais
ça chaque personnage pardon mais au
final ce sont au final je trouve que la
leçon reste la même piscine c'est quand
même assez positif si ça peut faire en
sorte que 10 go se disent ok - je vais
manger du manger du tofu continue à
faire mon jogging mon mater du vélo du
dj dessous allez vous qu'est ce que tu
veux faire
puis quand tu l'as bien performé puis ça
va être encore un gaulliste le mois
segan il dit pour la question des études
c'est très facile de trouver des études
devront se porter tes propos donc à
tibétains quelqu'un qui fait bien son
travail en venir c'est de regarder
qu'est-ce que l'encens à des études ou
de la littérature sur un sujet va donc
hanter la direction telle direction dont
ça se peut je reviens que les directions
mais aspire qu il existe une étude qui
montre que dans leurs études qu'ils ont
fait les gueux qui mangeaient vga vais
je sais pas quoi qu'il avait déplu
direction de tourner ça se peut que ça
vous dit que ça maintenant la vraie vie
on sait pas trop mais après ça est ce
que toutes les études de la même chose
c'est ce qui est intéressant
qui donc quand on regrette toutes les
études en sang même chose aux outils
quand il parle des hommes et ont un coût
qui vont ceci ne tient
c'est une étude si je me trompe pas que
cette étude là aussi mais qui avait été
aussi mais dont on a parlé aussi dans le
round up un autre documentaire son aide
l'x os qui compare sa cime et des
cigarettes dit c'est bon c'était pas une
étude qui était super bien faite puis
même les chercheurs en tant que tel dans
l'étude avait pas la même conclusion
c'est moi mais quand on met toutes les
études ensemble luttons sans compter que
oui mon gvg sa pleine bénéfices sur la
santé notamment moins de risques de
maladies cardiovasculaires
- de diabète qui sont deux maladies très
très très présents dans nos sociétés
donc oui semblait avoir des bénéfices
d'un point de vue de la santé
en plus ces bombes si le fun pipe mot
mais après ça c'est pas vrai quand tu
mets toutes les études que manger un
simple homme ou un beau du lait ou
manger un bout de viande c'est pas vrai
que ça va te tuer où ça va
nécessairement que tu vas voir le cancer
où ça va bouger des artères je pense que
c'est plus lopy pour ce que tu es moi de
manière générale je déteste les combats
d'articles ça arrive souvent qu'on peut
rentrer là dedans de me dire mais moi
j'ai une tite qui dit ça dans mes
commentaires sur facebook ça arrive mais
aussi des fois dans des débats qu'elle a
c'est quand même moi j'ai cette étude
qui s'appuie moi je ne sors jamais
gagnant dans le débat d'articles parce
qu'on va toujours trouver une petite
étude qui veut prouver nos propos nous
vraiment ce qu'on veut c'est toutes les
études enfants qu'est ce que ça nous
donne souvent aux sites et ses sorties
de dire comme ah bon il présentait des
études météo on peut présenter n'importe
quel étudiant es et l telle université
ou tel chercheur
ça peut être une étude de très mauvaise
qualité ça peut être une étude financée
par l'industrie ça peut être une et tout
est bon puis même je trouvais ça
intéressant parce que moment donné je te
demande dans l'épisode de joe rogan
jane's justement il prend ce site est
tellement un bon exemple
il prend une situation de crise que dans
l'épisode précédent
puis 10 je me rappelle même plus de quoi
le métier c'était comme la conclusion
puisque jean haja quelque chose en
guinée comme ce sadique web ce qu'ils
veulent mais celle ci qui avait pris
genre tu mets ton site tu manges
pourcentage
il y avait comme prigent repas de viande
est un peu de viande dont je me rappelle
plus t'es quoi mais c'est comme il y
avait pris une partie la statistique
pour 10 83% de 6 est-ce que ça a
augmenté les risques que je me rappelle
depuis quoi de consommer de la viande
puis dans 50% des cas
city avait aucune différence dans 23%
des que dans des jardins 14 % des coûts
y avait c'était il y avait plus de
chance dans 20% avait moins de chance
que lui a pris les 50 plus les 14 pour
dire dans 64% des cote +6 ou égales de
chant exact clottey claude gêne je n'ai
pu que le podcast
je ne comprends rien à votre excellence
en ce moment fait que je pense qu'il
faut juste qu'il y avait privé prix
genre le ça fait une différence ça fait
rien du tout où ça fait ça augmente les
risques maintenant il y avait pris le
pas de différence puis augmente les
risques qui les avait combiné puis de
loin mais moi je peux fait que le jam
mehdi ben moi je peux bien prendre le ça
ne fait rien du tout et ça c'est ça
diminue les risques ça va me faire une
belle donné mais ça va venir
complètement contredire ce que tu dis
s'effectue au choix c'est super
intéressant parce que finalement au-delà
de six oui c'est correct de citer des
études mais c'est l'interprétation de
ckoi la qualité ton études c'est qui qui
le finance et pis comment interpréter
résultats dans tes dents encore une fois
dans l'alimentation global séoul de dire
comme justement leur partant avec les
microdonnées percée de faire quelque
chose avec ce c'est très souvent le
recul que les joueurs arrivent dans
l'interprétation des résultats
donc quand je dis tu peux toujours
trouver quelque chose qui va être
supportés des fois tu peux trouver une
étude qui dit le contraire de ce que tu
dis mais d'ivresse à trouver une phrase
dans l'étude qui semble dire ce que tu
veux que je souhaitais c'était toute
cette phrase de la piste demain on
allait présenter une question grecque
encore une fois je dis pas que c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait je dis pas qu'ils ont un
n'importe qui touchent pas les dégâts
moi ce que je sais c'est quand on
regarde l'ensemble des études la plupart
des affirmations qui font sont
malheureusement fausses ou exagérées
oui mais je me genre de dire que manger
de la viande ça va non ce qui donne
aussi c'est que les deux gosses et
débattre pendant quatre heures au début
de podcasts c'est ce que je lui dis
témoin l'avait jeté mon assiette cdc des
végétaux je pense que de manger des
aliments d'erfoud dignement anti pilote
james et légumes et jay-z bas on on
argumente pourquoi mais après ce tir on
sait qu'il va argumenter sur justement
la validité des études c'est plus par an
première heure je pense que le débat
c'est ok bt toi tes études sont
financées par l'industrie
ouais mais le sillon si on va la refaire
toutes les études financées par
l'industrie respect rien enfin qu'il
faut quand même dit considérer dans la
nuit les recherches épistémologique
versus les recherches d'observation
qu'est ce qui va la vie pimentée coetze
comme c'est intéressant aux découpes
sidiki com qu'est-ce que ça change dans
ma vie à moi que moi j'applique cela
c'est l'ex si on agrandit le lointain si
on s'entend que j'écris un livre sur le
sujet
justement tu es sur comment interpréter
les résultats puis pas se faire avoir
par tout ce qu'on dit [ __ ] quand tu
dis ça sert à quoi
concentré de débattre en ce moment ça
sert au fait que moi personnellement je
pense que c'est important que les gens
aient accès à une information de qualité
puis qu'ils soient pas biaisé lemagit
possible ici pas que de moi même j'ai
mes billets même inconsciemment
rencontre mais c'est important pour moi
quand je vois une information de quelque
chose qui est hyper populaire comme ce
documentaire loi qui semble avoir une
répercussion vraiment important de sur
ben des gens non pour moi c'est vraiment
important de s'assurer puis de regarder
chacun 10 des faits qui justement pour
moi si les gens ressortent de ces
documentaires puis qui se disent amis
gays du genre faut absolument que
j'élimine la donne parce que je vais
mourir si j'en mange
mais là c'est trop sinon on rentre dans
la peur moi c'est pas de cette façon là
à mon avis qu'on devrait encourager les
gens d'autant plus que ça risque de
nuire à la crédibilité du mouvement soit
du mouvement vegan ou bien de
l'alimentation végétale peu importe
parce que c'est tellement facile de
détruire leurs arguments vic sont basés
sur pas grand chose que quand il détruit
après ça ça donne des arguments au
proviande mais tant qu'ils lisent à ath
voici le test des maudits vegan qui
voulaient nous faire croire ce pays
pauvre et avec manger la viande comme
vous voulez il est toujours un
contrebalance ex pour ce que moi je
pense mais important d'avoir
l'information la plus neutre puis comme
le paiement le plus près de ce que la
science nous dit six hôpitaux en bout de
ligne je te montre ce tableau que je 95%
du monde vont s'entendre dire qu'il faut
manger que des végétaux possible il faut
marcher de mettre en forme est possible
c'est comme une évidence mais même à son
en russie a absolument
sauf que par exemple que le documentaire
je pense qu'il est important piqué mais
quand même les ont pesé
cécilia quand même vraiment la croyance
est illégal thomas des protéines
propofol
il a on vienne encore sub c'est le fun
ce fait j'ai l'impression que si on
avait hâte il se passe des documentaires
qui sont grand public peuvent pas je
pars pas par définition mais parce visés
peuvent pas établir les faits de façon
claire et nuancée et etp au
sensationnalisme
parce que faire se regarder si tu
voulais dire moi j'ai arrêté de manger
de la viande
ben ça se peut que in an mais c'est ça
pour vrai mais ça se pose jamais la
question oui mais je sais c'est pas
intéressant justement passé vraiment
c'est l'exemple
oui c'est clair pour tout le monde ça
reste darnal puis c'est ça moi je pense
que c'est sûr que l'exagération pilar
lama ration l'histoire c'est sûr que
c'était voulu c'est sûr que c'est sûr
qu'ils ont qui ont dit on met tout ce
qui est le plus flashé de la vente qui
avec bach et par la science la science
est en ciel qui nous dit que manger plus
de végétaux c'est bon qu'on peut tout
faire quand même
mais mettons tout le plus flashé à 20
pour faire jaillir une vérité qui va
intéresser les gens parce que tu peux
pas faire un documentaire comme ça aussi
fondé profonde et mai font des de l'oci
à financer aussi grand budget grand
public peep offert de quoi qui est
intéressante et captivante
ça n'a pas été aussi vu ça n'a plus le
même impact puisque parce que c'est
celle des grandes des baux derrière ce
film louper ce genre de documentaire c
est ce que est ce qu'elle est ce que la
fin justifie les moyens
elle concerne à l'isthme qui est ce que
justement utiliser des clichés
d'exagérer un peu parfois pour que plus
de gens adoptent une diète avec moins de
viande ou vegan parce qu'ils étaient en
bout de ligne
maintenant les points de l'environnement
est un petit peu traitée dans le film
par la fin c'est pas le point majeur
mais on en parle et on parle pas du tout
des tic animal on en parle un peu ou
presque votre grille comme chi chi chi
chi le en charge pour former les
gardes-chasse pour protéger les
trappeurs et lui dit c'est ma vie à
former du monde pour protéger des
animaux mais je sais qu'on a parlé sur
curtis c'est vraiment un documentaire
qui majoritairement et d'en faire de la
santé puis je pense que pour la majorité
des vegan c'est quand même
l'argument environnemental disque
animales sont beaucoup plus importants
oui on est pourtant effet mais je pense
que je pense que le film ne m'en prends
le moyen la santé pour convaincre des
gens mais que le réel but c'est d'avoir
un impact environnemental et un impact
ou thé ou le real but l'attention
l'intention de la connais pas masquer
une résultante de tout une conséquence
de ce savon nécessairement être se fait
que le est-ce que ce que c est ici qu
est ce que c est ce que ça se fait ce
qu'on devrait utiliser sur des clips
documentaires lui pour arriver à nos
fins à un twist 1.6 sacrifions déjà le
documentaire s'adresser aux roses ac
l'été ou ou sportifs l'allemand et que
les sportifs vont peut-être leur
motivation à faire des changements dans
leur alimentation va être plus axé sur
la santé
mais c'est vrai que ça s'adresse surtout
aux jeunes par exemple aux mets mais
c'est vrai que si on regarde les
motivations puisque ça a été longtemps
la santé il de dire je vais manger ceci
ou moins de cela ça longtemps été la
santé mais le vrai changement le haut
niveau d'aidé des motivations de ces
comportements talent
natation c'est beaucoup plus
l'environnement de succès que ce soit
dire je vais manger local bio afghane
c'est beaucoup plus l'environnement que
dois je vais manger bio pour ma santé à
moins dénonce pour la santé la france et
le c'est le but
j'aimerais avoir votre opinion là dessus
c'est qu'encore manger un morceau de
viande de veau porc de tuer ce c'est
définitif des jeux tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus une diète
maintenant on doit point de vue
nutrition une diète balancer de raw food
vaud avec beaucoup de végétaux vont être
bonnes pour tous si je pense que on
s'entend là-dessus tout le monde ou est
ce que la salle où est-ce que ça
accroche c'est de dire tu peux continuer
à manger du steak est une fois par
semaine si matt ont mangé du steak une
fois par semaine d'un point de vue
nutritionnel on s'en fout tu somme toute
si le résident la semaine ccvg
par contre le site toute la planète avec
la voulait manger du state qui était pas
de l'industrie agroalimentaire trois
polluants trop vraiment mauvaise pour
l'éthique animale tchèque qui
maltraitent les animaux et tout fera
qu'à manger un steak une fois par trois
mois pour que toutes les animaux
souffrir un tchèque
comment est-ce que vous en tant que
nutritionniste
on peut on mais comment vous pouvez
modifier le message parce que je
comprends que de dire
d'un point de vue nutritionnel vous
pouvez continuer en réduisant un petit
peu mais réduire un petit peu
globalement c'est vraiment pas suffisant
l'espace pour réduire beaucoup un
contrat les comportements alimentaires
des gens la viande de sa première même
beaucoup de place encore c'est moi ça
fait des années que des années des
années des années que j'ai fait pendant
des années j'ai acheté pas de viande
chez moi ces gens mangeaient
bon si j'allais chez mes parents ou quoi
que ce soit le jeu j'en achète mais un
peu le tir en fin de semaine mais si on
regarde les comportements de
consommation
je pense qu'on peut on a encore de la
place le pour réduire pas mal notées ou
pour reprendre le côté possible de
bernard de dj l'instant la place pour
les végétaux
on a vraiment de place pour les végétaux
en natation mais je sais pas mais moi je
pense que c'est un point qui ont ni
nutritionnistes ont fait partie de notre
profession
donc on est tenu de bases ethno
d'information sur la santé
toutefois ce quelqu'un me dit est ce que
je peux manger de la viande ça votre
attitude dangereux mais non je peux dire
dangereux donc c'est impossible pour moi
de te mentir pour la santé on peut pas
mais ce que vous êtes tenu aussi de
parler de la science au delà de la
science de la santé
vous pouvez pas obtenir combat
environnement s'est pas tenue qui nous
intéresse beaucoup
moi depuis le début mon discours
toujours été de diminuer la viande qui
devait pas donner de quantité tic comme
ceux du bsc une fois par semaine moi je
donne jamais de quantité moi ce que je
te dise et mangeant moins souvent si la
personne va mange tous les jours
ben si je dit elle c'est une fois par
trois mois un gros match que tu pourrais
manger avant midi donc il faut réaliser
aussi que les gens sont pauvres andulo
nécessairement puis juste avec moi ça
m'arrive encore là quand je donne des
conférences juste dire aux gens
dites-moi gsb diminuer la consommation
de viande le des fois j'ai encore des
gens qui me regardent genre de même
jeudi je vous dis pas qu'il faut
absolument être végétarien le dans votre
vie juste manger moins souvent non
peut-être un repas par semaine que vous
cuisinez pas de viande à rien et c'est
comme si je n'ai dollars ouais faict
comprends que les gens ne sont pas moi
mon premier livre de recettes le saper
les carnivores infidèles
j'écris ça en 2011 quand même comme ça
fait longtemps qu'ils je pense que le
commentaire le plus le plus
fréquent que j'ai reçu c'était or c'est
comme ton livre ça m'a tellement envie
de la pression parce que je passe quel
est le mot carnivores dans le titre je
sentais que j'avais encore le droit de
manger de la viande qui montrent la même
chose le cpo genre aubin le faut que tu
fasses x ex nombre de repas dans ta
semaine vj c'était juste peace tige
j'allais pas loin là dans mon enfant il
ya un autre fromage des heures qu'ils
étaient il ya vraiment beaucoup trop de
produits laitiers dans les temps les
recettes par à petit je le fais
aujourd'hui je composerai merci
différemment mais bref
le fait de dire comme écoute je t'ai
type de prêt à manger je te dis juste
que c'est possible d'en manger moins
c'est comme pour reprendre le titre de
ton livre ça ce repas platoir remis
c'est ce sera pas pu s'asseoir pu by the
brain sang coule comme liste de tours de
tourteaux miel donnons à manger grandes
lettres subjectif mais pis ça a commencé
cette espèce de mouvement de dire comme
ça peut être super bon encore une fois
je reviens avec avec mon côté
découvertes et tu voyages un peu là des
recettes vegan souvent manger pas mal
qui s'est jamais plat le suivant le plan
national c'est le fameux rice and beans
le jan en tabarouette lambin des pays
puis c'est super bon ben c'est tout et
tout t'as pas l'impression de privés ou
de dire comment je peux jouer comme
panier dans mon titre c'est super et
puis je pense que si on est là dedans
c'est beaucoup moins c'est beaucoup
moins stressant c'est beaucoup moins
restrictif peas et c'est ça tu sais pas
c'est pas d'hier
disponible c'est juste de dire comme ok
comment je peux changer les
comportements
puis évidemment ça va faire en sorte
qu'au moment où il sait que ça fasse en
sorte qu' on puisse changer nos
pratiques d'élevage c'est parce que
c'est vrai que si on continue de
consommer de la viande comme on en
consomme aujourd'hui le sud de changer
son nom mais trop c'est souvent seul
argument de sa marche pas le l'élevage
en pâturage ou les deux les petites
productions parce que ça c'est
impossible que ça
sada de la viande qu'on consomme c'est
vrai des élevages bio non mais c'est
surtout 88
mais si cet effet que c'est comme si on
veut râle si on veut un changement réel
dans le dans le blanc la méthode
d'élevage saucisson est à l'aise avec le
fait de tuer des animaux pour les manger
faut changer nos habitudes le thé sa
potence puis moi j'ai l'impression puis
on a parlé aussi avec bob le chef je le
mentionnais un petit peu mais j'ai
l'impression que dans sur tous les
points de vue le thé plus je parle pour
la planète c'est que ce soit sur
l'électrification des transports ce soit
sur notre émission de gaz à effet de
serre le plastique à usage unique tous à
faire là j'ai l'impression que ça prend
un virage à 180 degrés
lol puis cac quand on dit augmenter sa
consommation de végétaux
j'ai l'impression que il y en a qui vont
il ya des gens qui vont recevoir cette
information là puis dire ok scarlett
niche mais c'est encore correct de
manger de la viande à tous les jours une
fois par jour du puits moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut tourner le
gouvernail crissement a plus qu il se
retire
j'ai eu une discussion avec une
nutritionniste justement à l'ailé vegan
ouais elle écrit des livres sur le
végétarisme the north d'un coup qui
guérit pas mais c'est bon elle pense
beaucoup comme toi elle est année est ce
que cette année que des gens comme moi
ou d'autres on dise on compare le
plaisir quoi qu'on dise que pour parce
que pour moi les changements vont se
faire dans le plaisir on est d'accord là
dessus mais elle est d'y jeter corps et
du plaisir parce que c'est plus du
plaisir qu'on a besoin on est dans une
catastrophe absolue il faut tout ce
qu'on change immédiatement je re
d'accord mais je comprends son argument
mais je pense pas que ça va marcher
s'était pas d'accord parce que tu passes
pacs qui se pense pas que c'est le
message est reçu et qui les gens vont
changer pour cette afrique
et on guérit fidèle toute sa vie c'est
comme le fait de dire de manger moins de
viande par exemple de conserver cette
ligne directrice là je pense que ça rend
mon discours plus pas la table pour bien
des gens qui veulent le végétarisme
c'est une autre planète puis capote pays
où ils voient ils écoutent les nouvelles
et voiture voilée vegan ils ont mis de
la colle dans ses rues j'exagère mais
comment est ce que je veux dire pour
aussi c'est un autre gang complètement
qu' ils ne peuvent pas adhérer à sonne
mais ces gens ne voient jamais les
convaincre mais c'est cette fois ci un
peu utile si on prend justement pour
reprendre les trucs plus
environnementaux disons de dire pour le
plastique à usage unique
est ce que bon c'est sûr que le ton mais
ton libre et au bon sens on est d'accord
avec ça mais là de dire ok moi je vais
éliminer le plastique à usage unique de
2 me coûter chez moi c'est plus rentable
comme obsédé le ti comme effectivement
j'essaie de me dire ok moi comme
personne oui c'est sûr que
l'environnement ça me touche énormément
qu'est-ce que je peux faire comme
changement kiki ce repas sera pas et ça
va pas augmenter sa sont pas une source
de stress
c'est pas compliqué plus en ce moment
c'est mon truc c'est d'en porter mais
contenant comme à l'épicerie et c-zero
un stress une habitude à prendre je
pense pas tout le temps puis des fois
juste et je parle je marche hitchcock
j'ai encore oublié crûment c'est
vraiment une habitude à prendre
c'est pas stressant c'est pas compliqué
je fais pas de détours qui comme si
vraiment c'est vraiment juste une
habitude à prendre
je pense qu'on peut avoir cette même ce
petit cette même habitude le en
alimentation pic saint loup puis c'est
pas encore une fois ne s'est pas de dieu
comme je me tape sa tête parce qu'il
faudrait donc pas que je mange de poulet
outils de fromage on sait pas quoi non
si c'est si c'est positif de repos
l'impression de très strictes d'europe a
l'impression de te taper sur la tête
parce que faut que je mange et lentilles
aujourd'hui tu sais comme vous comme moi
je continue
désir c'est comme c'est comme
l'entraînement c'est que n'importe quoi
c'était pas de plaisir à le faire
exactement ce cadre pas dans la durée
c'est celui ci vous vu quelqu'un qui
mange moins une viande toute sa vie que
quelqu'un qui est vegan pendant six mois
pin en jambes elle trop c'est tout moche
pour lui racheter totalement ça mais
c'est vraiment intéressant parce qu'on a
encore une fois je reviens avec l'unique
n'utilisons pas ce printemps si les
trois on est vraiment dans une espèce
d'optique de comme bienveillance qui
comme la douce soirée comme comment est
ce qu'on fait pour avoir des messages
qui vont pas comme justement remet la
pression sur les gens qui évidemment
l'unît à l'effet gan qui tous ces
questionnements l'odeur qui on va pas
amener la culpabilité chez les gens
parce qu'on l'a vu en nutrition on l'a
beaucoup vu de sur la santé mettons en
commençant de grossir tu vas voir si
pisapia m'ont dit tu devrais pas manger
si je ne veux pas manger ça hein ça
marche pas parce que les gens ça fait
chier les stresser davantage puis le
stress c'est vraiment pas bon pour la
santé
explorez que s'améliorent nécessairement
avis étaient stressés qui change mais on
peut c'est ce que ça sera pas durable
après c'est avec l'environnement la même
chose qui je dis je je
j'écris à mon premier livre son
environnement que je comprends traîner
des enjeux puis moi je pense qu'on
devrait il ya plein de produits que je
consomme pas du tout du tout parce que
je me dis aux mains que l'on devrait
tellement pas mais non du temps on va
dire que pour moi c'est comme impensable
qu'on mange encore du temps mais jamais
je casse la pâte et au japon mais méfiez
pourquoi pour les gens qu'ils écoutent
de comprendre pourquoi tu dis ça mais
n'en reste plus ok c'est pas compliqué à
comprendre
non mais l'été de temps tous les types
de thons la procédure la fin c'est que
bon malheureusement c'est que l'undd kim
et moi dans mon premier league chez
comme acquis de thon rouge avec les yeux
doux aux espèces qu'ils peuvent mais
leur rends compte que ballon on ne
soutient votre espèce pions se met à les
vider toutes les espèces de temps ok
mais jamais je dis j'en conserve le crs
comme un espèce de bons vendeurs encore
mais oui mais c'est ça mais le tunisien
envahi par populace dans les numéros un
mais moi dans la vie je peux dire aux
gens de manger du thon mais jamais de
façon ne souhaite pas parce que tu en as
mangé ou jamais de jeudi comme de quoi
que ce soit parce que je n'ai pas être
sept voiles de
la genre de la culpabilité ici je veux
que tu continues à pas m'écouter je pose
pour un professeur le métis trouvera
comme si je veux que tu compte que même
mes propos continuent à résonner en toi
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut que je
reste dans cet article de bienveillance
et gentillesse pilier faut que ça reste
doux parce que des mamans est ce qu'on
va utiliser la culpabilité comme acteur
moteur de changement ça va pas être je
pense que je pense que c'est parfait
qu'il ya une diversité de messages parce
que c'est pas le même message il faut
fonctionner par la même personne ait des
gens justement qu'un message plus doux
plus diminué sur être bon pour ta santé
ils ont un impact positif dans les
rendements métier 12 13 mai puis déjà de
l'autre ça va fonctionner et déjà tu
leur dis hé lol il ya une urgence
climatique ça ça vaut pas bon mais la
chose la plus la plus importante la
chose qui va le plus d'un paquet préface
l'environnement c'est devenir végétarien
de nevegal encore mieux ok il ya des
gens pour qui ça ça va fonctionner si
les différents messages et qui vont
rejoindre différents publics j'aime bien
sûr absolument jaser j'avais cette
conversation a justement sutto au stunt
d'activistes vegan qu'ils aient lieu au
duo bfk précieux dans d'autres
restaurants
j'avais de quoi s'assurer que ma blonde
nuage moi je me questionne énormément
quant à la pertinence de faire ça à quel
point c'est bénéfique pour le mouvement
versus le backlash que ça peut amener
puis jetés en train de regarder à lcn je
pense que celle ci n le site et jean
philippe petit sourire qui était en
entrevue à lcn pour parler de ce pour
parler de ce que les activistes avaient
fait que j'ai dit à ma blonde comment à
quoi ça sert surtout l'âme répondu tout
de suite
jean philippe et à lcn avec tout le
monde en parle que le monde en parle
positivement ou négativement
tu mets ça sur la place publique après
ça tu envoies ton meilleur porte parole
[ __ ] c'est pas comme si tout cela
était planifié le tiens mais ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la personne qui va
convertir le plus de vegan par la
fourchette comme il aime le dire est un
ancien pour parler de dieu pour dire que
lui se pose à ces mouvements le mais que
fait qu'au final vous asseyant oui la
presse négative par rapport à cet angle
mais si elle pas eu cette ampleur il y
avait aucune raison de parler de sa
radio radio et télé at il dit d'ailleurs
il dit oui et 10 pas fait à quoi est dû
à quoi ça sert je suis c'est exact
l'exact puis c'est vrai c'est vrai que
j'ai lu j'ai lu l'année passée le
manifeste des extinctions ribéry
justement sont pour les actions non
violent de rébellion armée qui est un
peu comme ça pis a m'a aussi ouvert les
yeux plus là dessus puis justement je me
rends compte qu'on a besoin je copie je
vais être je mets de mes gambettes dire
que je n'encourage poc aucun geste mais
effectivement je pense qu'une diversité
de thématiques vont avoir des
répercussions différents - mettons donc
mais je sais moi j'ai la pop de l'année
moi je pense que c'est bon pour eux
sandjak tout ce qu'ils ont dit oui ils
ont eu c'est un message dans leur boîte
aux lettres de la colle dans la serrure
inquiets ils ont eu droit besson lui des
analystes à l'intérieur ça a duré du
soir et ça finit le premier problème à
rembourser les clients puis ils sont
trop paresseux en a parlé pendant deux
semaines complètes dizaines de milliers
centaines de milliers de dollars de bons
du tout pour une fois je suppose
nouvelle acura jockey
chose mais quand même beaucoup parlé
puis j'ai écouté j'ai coûté une autre
vue mettant des proprios du manitoba way
pis j'ai déjà acquis fnam en entrevue
salameh vraiment valeur j'aime beaucoup
la lettre qui fait que justement je
tekoa qui finalement ça a été comme un
coup de pub pour elle aussi
ensuite tout le monde j'ai pas mal c'est
que c'est quand même de rouge pense pas
que le mouvement a eu vraiment backlash
énorme le oui non mais c'est plus dans
le sens que tu es bon mois moscou mais
ce qui m'a fâché c'est que je me disais
quand l'insee moi mes amis vegan sont
pas de même ces pistes étaient amis sont
probablement poussées le pire on peut en
parler sur une des amies son parlement
végétaliens qui s'y sont vegan sont
peut-être pas activer cette vigueur mais
mettons mois les dickens mal c'est de
plus en plus important dans ma vie ça
allait quand même pas mal maintenant
puis quand qu'on parle de leurs projets
de la petit abattoir
c'était cela ferrat mouassa mécanisme
des cashes l'entendant seul pourquoi
parce que ça reste de faire quelque
chose pour tuer des animaux saisir et on
fait quelque chose puis tout le monde se
tape dans le dos tout le monde est
content pour ouvrir une affaire pour
tuer des animaux puis ce pour des pour
des végétaliens qu'ils font pour
l'environnement ou pour la santé vous
avez mettons un végétalien va peut-être
avoir un manteau de cuir parce que pour
l'environnement on s'en fout tu es
vraiment parce que c'est un sous-produit
de de l'animal mais mais pour un vegan
ça vaut vraiment au delà de juste ton
alimentation pisi que eu un moment donné
comment tu fais pour amener la question
de l'éthique animale au sein du débat
c'est le monde
on parlait des tons liliane depuis ton
le monde sont prêts à marcher ses mains
pour pau prendre de pâques en plastique
parce que ça tue des poissons mais ce
qu'ils sont qui se bat pas prêt à faire
par exemple s'est arrêté de manger des
poissons pour m'arrêter
et poissons très fort mais c'est ça pour
vrai en place et qu'il n'est que ses
atouts des poissons y arrête d'en manger
aussi cela tue 100 % des poissons
dimanche sont tués mais sauf qu est ce
que tu comprend quel point que puis je
suis vraiment d'accord avec toi puis
jamais j'aurai un argument pour dire au
nom le véganisme n'est pas bon non
jamais mais est-ce que tu comprends à
quel point ça veut dire que c'est
difficile et non mais de changer des
comportements raison du problème puis ça
pour ça moi je pense que c'est là dessus
qu'on doit t contre qu'on doit
travailler parce que oui si on était
tout des machines qu'on vivait tout cela
comme des robots c'était super facile
auprès des interdits bien c'est fini il
n'y en a plus donc faut qu'on prenne
d'autres - axe d'autres actions pour
être capable d'arriver fierté mais est
ce que pour revenir au petit abattoir
est ce que parce que moi évidemment je
me suis posé plein de questions aussi
apprêtée vont cesser ces évènements le
film à dire ok on cible le petit
abattoir mais comme qu'est ce qu'on en
fait dès mes gueux gros abattoirs que
les autorités c'est comme un camp c'est
pis parce que autant évidemment comme
l'éthique animale c'est je pense le
bien-être je faisais le bien-être parce
que je vous j'en mange de la viande
dompter jeu pibou mon père chasse et
quand j'étais jeune fectivement le
concept de manger un animal mort ça
jamais été comme un jeune du poulet
venait pas de l'épicerie le thé mais on
dirait que je pissais vraiment le comme
je trouve ça un peu fou d'avoir la
réflexion lola parce que c'est vraiment
une réflexion j'ai pas de réponse je
sais pas trop quoi en penser
mais est-ce que encore une fois pour
voyager beaucoup on dirait que je me dis
tuer des animaux pour les manger dans
comme toutes les côtes ou presque toutes
les cultures du monde sait ça fait
partie du cycle on peut on peut pour
répondre à des questions lors venir au
documentaire c'est qu'ils prouvent hors
de tout doute que c'est plus nécessaire
- si ça ne fait que c'est culturellement
le ton le fait parce que c'était
nécessaire parce qu'on avait rien
d'autre
c'est plus du tout nécessaire prévu fait
comment qu'on peut justifier ses
agissements le temps des êtres moraux
qu'il aime les chicons gala de penser
mais pour revenir
pourquoi s'attaquer au petit abattoir à
place d'abattoirs de masse c'est que les
alentours de masse sont à qui on sait
qu'ils sont là puis il ya personne qui
se félicite d'entasser des animaux dans
des cages pour les lis tu es le tir de
façon complètement politique mais là
c'est comme le propos et ses propos et
sinon je pense que ça a vraiment heurter
les vegan parce que le steak hommes
félicitations ouais on fait quelque
chose d'autre pour tous les animaux tout
le monde est content que ces dons ben
beau projet mais notre île québec là
dedans peas et kamla c'est que dans
l'esprit je pense que dans l'esprit de
tv ganda postaux que tu portes bien dans
ton esprit suis un animal c'est un crime
que tu fasses une fois où mille fois
gentiment pas gentiment gentiment
correctives je comprends évidemment si
pour toi un animal est au moins un pied
d'égalité au lit même la même droit font
de même droits fondamentaux qu'un humain
soit la grimace tu crois que tu croit la
théorie de darwin pas mal ces temps
arrive le déclassement si c'est
l'évolution piqué tout le monde vient de
la même souche b si nous on a des droits
fondamentaux d'un portique évoluer dans
le même temps dans mes vêtements est un
des droits fondamentaux et on s'est dit
qu'on con qu'on partage même adn que
tout ce qui vit sa planète les animaux
pitié on le sait pour un fait qu'il ya
un animal comme le cochon comme la vache
un niveau de conscience qui comprend ce
qui se passe que promettre l'enfer c'est
pire semblait en faire aussi
après ça donc c'est ce ticket le
parallèle avec avec l' esclavage ou avec
étaient des problématiques humaines
duquel qui était quelque chose
propriétaire de un esclave ou de 45
je crée une petite un crime quand même
donc
donc si je sais pas je pense que c'est
cela dans l'esprit d'un éveil ânes que
tu le fasses mieux qu'on fasse moins
changerait que je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser comme et c'est vrai qu'ils ont
dans les sociétés occidentales
c'est plus un besoin de moi je sais
c'est pas nécessaire on peut tout dire
on peut avoir une alimentation très
équilibré pas avoir tout ce qu'on a
besoin en mangeant avec un problème ou
végétales
mais il reste quand même que dans
certaines dans certains pays ou dans
certaines communautés le la pêche ou la
l'élevage ces dix élevage de te joindre
aux poulpes inite et puis tu manges la
viande comme une fois par semaine puis
c'est comme tu sais ça coûte super cher
c'est que ce maquettiste une célébration
un peu comme ce l'était dans les années
40 l'outil m'ont dit que honnêtement je
pense que si ces communautés le sait
c'est évident il y en a qui en mangent
plus pisser culture et l'autre intérêt
mais six s'y arrêter de manger toute
forme de produits animaux je pas sûr que
l'allemand leur alimentation serait
complète mais ce tu vois cc c'est là que
c'est moi je parle même pas de ceux qui
sont au nord que c'est la seule façon
bientôt nous résoudrons la nécessité vu
ces électrons qu'un impact son
environnement non c'est ça exactement
exactement affectés on revient encore à
ça nous y tu peux aller oui j'ai eu vite
fait je changeais d'aller ouais j'en
retiens le plus gros effort que tu peux
faire pour arrêter cette exploitation
doit s' est chargé d'aller
effectivement on s'entend que c'est pas
de la nécessité puis moi j'ai même amis
chasseurs aux petits s'ils vont chasser
une fois puis que s'ils mangent le mange
le génial pour toute l'année la leur
dire tu es moins ça ça me perturbe pas
au même titre que de mettre au monde des
animaux pour les abuser et puis le fait
que fait facture pour dire faux secours
d'autres activistes sont adressés joby
les autres les autres parce que l'oeil à
puyoo plus de façons de faire passer ce
message là autrement que de faire
arrêter
c'est vrai que ça finisse leur mue qui
sur ce que je pense que il va continuer
d'en avoir des actions comme ça je pense
même que c'est important qu'ils en
auraient peut-être c'est sûr que ça
stigmatise un petit peu le mouvement
mais au final je pense que si pour la
cause je pense que c'est juste positif
c'est possible permettant peut-être que
ça va faire mais notez que je vais le
jouer loin mais peut-être qu'à un
certain moment parce que moi mais c'est
une question d'identité
quand est ce que tu dis mais je suivais
gamme donc tu as tu sais ton identique
identifiée à ce mouvement lot identifié
à ce niveau j'ai moi personnellement la
viande des pratiques et des animaux ça
fait pas vraiment partie mon
alimentation seror j'en mangeais six
jeunes évitée chez quelqu'un ouais
qu'immense argent manche puis je me
contente et je n'ai quand même puis j'ai
passé pour des questions morales manquer
moi je ne suis pas vegan d'une sauvage
et alliés végétarien je ne m'identifie
tarrier peut-être que c'est l'ami
d'antibes et je m'identifie pas parler
[Rires]
mais mais saupoudrez je m'identifie pas
à mon alimentation du jamais senti le
besoin mais peut-être aussi abandonnés
çà vous demande de venir de plus en plus
rare de consommer des animaux attendant
futur que les gens vont moins sentir le
besoin justement de s'identifier à des
mouvements puis ça va juste comme donner
plus répandue et puis ça va devenir la
nouvelle norme
puis je pense encore une fois avec des
messages de réduction plutôt que
d'élimination tels que c'est vrai c'est
qu'on change la norme versus on a besoin
de toujours besoin puis j'aime je peux
être
j'ai utilisé quand même si c'est pas
exactement ce que je dis mais on a
besoin d' extrémistes entre guillemets
du moins qui sont loin de la norme
sociale
donc je dis pas que ces propos
péjoratifs comme termes que ce que
j'utilise mais juste besoin que si les
vegan sont loin de la norme sociale en
ce moment on a besoin de ces gens là
pour tirer dans tous les sens tous les
mouvements sociaux de ces métaux
comprend l'homosexualité c'est ça le
prix des parades avec des fanfares des
gens en cuir est pour que pour tirer la
norme sociale vers pis moi quand j'étais
jeune je voyais ça je me disais qu'il
paye d'abord en urgence posture je
m'identifiais pas du tout à ce qui j'ai
beaucoup d'amis xi qui s'identifie petit
quand mon ordi mais qui s'identifient
pas à ces mouvements le pied après ça en
lisant sur le sujet par comprenant
pourquoi ces gestions dû être posée que
je fais que le ch pierre piskor world
comme si fous ont eu besoin de ces gens
là qui justement ont fait parler d'eux
pour montrer ses on a eu besoin de ce
fait que peut-être que c'est un peu la
même chose dans un certain sens que si
comme peut-être que des gens qui
s'identifieront pas assez viril mais pas
du tout à ça mais je n'irai jamais je
n'aurais jamais dans une manifestation
avec à deux confrontations laitiers ou
est-ce que tu en as une place pilote
hutues mon été j'ai fait des
manifestations silencieuses ou est-ce
qu'on est allé marcher dans une
pour pour sensibiliser à la cause métier
moi je n'anticipe pas à ce groupe car
quand je le marginalise pas de temps que
d'autres encore dont le condamner au nom
si seul le contente parce que j'ai
trouvé très c'est que justement je
trouvais que ça encourage et comme les
gens qui qui ont perçu ces
manifestations le de façon très négative
c'est comme ça fait juste nourrir leur
ces gens là j'ai l'impression
j'ai vraiment l'impression que il ya un
genre est un groupe de gens qui vont
mourir en mangeant de la viande trois
fois par jour louis piques une fois que
cette génération là va être passé à
autre chose
on va être ailleurs on en parle souvent
souvent souvent mais il ya aussi réagi
sur stecher martineau était lui ces
filles sont vg freine lille et y fait
lui s'est opposé drastiquement stoutz
électeurs allemands qui sont montés
forclaz et vegan qui nous donnent tout
leur enfant ou six ans exactement tout
le monde dit la même chose qu'il ya même
une jarre de frustration mais le nom des
parents qui viennent me voir le sifflet
oui mais oui c'est c'est tout le monde
ville seront avec moi j'ai l'impression
que ce vraiment que sont opposés
drastiquement sur les jo bhi feu de ce
monde le wiki qui était fâché de ces
agissements là j'ai l'impression que
d'autres pas grand chose qu'on va
pouvoir faire mater même pays sont au
courant que chez les imagine que c'est
une strate plutôt masculine
fin quarantaine début cinquantaine qui
sont ce groupe le qui se pose tellement
drastiquement se met aux autres à moins
qu'ils se rendent compte à emmener qui
souffrent de maladies cardiovasculaires
puis que l'offre faut absolument qu'ils
diminuent je pense qu'ils ont une
direction ou qui ont vu des réactions
exactement c'est jean-philippe dit
problème de quéquette change ton
assiette même et c'est sûrement avec moi
je pense que c'est ce qui aurait
assurément fortement compte ce j'ai pas
beaucoup d'espoir dans la conversion la
conversion éventuelle pas le mot
conversion mais là le change c'est ce
changement durable puis ça c'est une
autre chose aussi voulait aborder avec
vous dernièrement on voyait la diète
c'est aux jeunes me rappelle plus et
qu'il a dit c'est nous qui était invité
à denis lévesque pour parler de tout
mais qui dit que c'était pas une diète
qui était capitaine qui étaient
maintenus lundi et qui avait un taux
d'abandon vie élevé de sessad exactement
exactement 2 par la restriction que ça
que ça mais peu importe le type de diète
restrictive que ça soit s'en vient
avec vienne avec grue a pas beaucoup de
gras et pour beaucoup de galeries et
tatati souvent ça ça on décroche là les
causes qu'on voit le canton via les
études sur les mettant sur les pertes de
poids on veut dire donc les gens qui
modifient leur alimentation dans le but
d'une perte de poids dans les cinq
années suivantes jusqu'à 90% des gens
vont avoir repris le poids donc ils
auront abandonné ce cas ça marche pour
des billes ça ne marche pas et encore je
tape sur le cloud quand tu changes tout
jour au lendemain il semble y avoir un
petit quand même 10 % chez qui ça a
marché mais c'est vraiment vraiment pas
la majorité
parce que dès que tu sens une
restriction peu importe la kelly
ça ne va pas marcher qui pour faire
régner avec le végétalisme si tu deviens
végétalien jour au lendemain mais que tu
sens des restrictions sur l'achat
le plaisir est super important si tu
veux que ça qu'est satine sur le long
terme ceci comme une composante qu'on ne
peut pas jamais envie de l'alimentation
parce que dans la vie de ce fait rien
tempo tout le temps vous toujours à
l'alimentation ça j'adore gaz
à ce jour la science ne pas dériver sauf
que c est magique
ça fait tache comme ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on sait je suis vraiment
pas le premier à le dire il ya plein
d'organismes de santé publique au québec
et ailleurs dans le monde qu'il répète
depuis toujours
l'or ne lui olive encore une fois
l'unique être un piment de lui-même
livre qui s'appelle un petit d'ayette
qui vraiment sur justement sa culture
laser avec les chipies justement à pour
cette lignée mais je suis dit que je
devais devenir plus restrictive qu'a
sorti un livre s'appellera ou not to die
est ok parce que lui avait valu en
attendant son premier mais je pense
quand même un bon mouvement le la dalle
comme le phoque et d'ail et puis ce qui
sépare les fondations de reims à g
oui en fait christian olsson
un podcast aussi les foudres 5e qui est
vraiment intéressant qui justement sur
cette culture de la diète puis comment
que ça marche pop que les gens se lança
dans pi souffre plus que coach journée
vraiment très très fun mais ont visité
de mon pauvre et ouais c'est ça mon post
je m'attendais pas à avoir des réactions
autant c'est vraiment fou l'un gens sont
tellement les gens sont tellement dans
cette culture
je peux voir plus comme un paradigme
plongeurs j'en profite je reviens encore
avec le véganisme mettons donc le quart
nice lucky luke à nice mettant le fait
que c'est normal naturel nécessaire de
manger de la viande compter dans ce
paradigme là tu ne vois pas les autres
chaînes hôtelières comme ça le jour où
tu comprends c'est quoi le charisme
pictures et alice coste un paradigme des
pompiers que que tu en sors un peu tu
réalises comme au hockey puis moi c'est
un peu comme si pour ce que je dis
jamais je donnais un argument contre le
véganisme parce que ça se peut pas ça
existe un peu justement par les autres
meilleurs paradigme sur le poids puis
sur la diète sur le fait que être mince
c'est mieux qu est gros grosso modo tous
les résumés comme ça que ce soit pour
ton apparence que ce soit pour ta santé
que ce soit pour n'importe quoi il vaut
mieux être même ce qui est gros ce qui
est faux sang soo steeple
il faut être prête en santé mais c'est
juste que on a tellement mis on met
tellement ceux de l'avant que les gens
sont prêts à tout pour perdre du poids
mais la réalité c'est qui peut être en
santé peu importe on voit les habitudes
de vie c'est super important c'est qu'on
s'en tire dessus
qu'est ce que tu fais une certaine mais
betty mettons l'obésité morbide est pas
morte pour rien certains dessus acquis
jeu mais non
pas de noms mais honnêtement c'est
vraiment beaucoup de choses à détricoter
je te jure c'est la même chose que les
gens qui ont tripé un genre comprendre
le charisme puis comme sorties d'un
paradigme lisier sur la culture de la
diète qui vous allez comprendre c'est
aussi trippant intellectuellement de
comprendre qu'il ya plein de mythes
autour de soi notamment l'imc quiconque
on considère qu'elle aime si ces gens
une bonne façon les antisémites
c'est vraiment pas en fait c'est que
liam 6 est vraiment pas un indice de
qualité
ok comme non c'est surtout pis si c'est
vraiment remis de plus en plus en cause
pis donc les termes obésité ou obésité
morbide ça vient de l'imc des cellules
créées par sa donc démonte dur mais en
deuxième cible faudrait aussi que se
remettent en doute les les labos
économie basée sur cet outil le dax a
remis en doute vraiment vraiment
beaucoup d'affaires pis c'est le jeu
c'est trop long pour tout rentrer mes
parents mais des gens qui sont qui ont
qui sont aux berges de l'aveyron ce
qu'on veut dire ben est ce que c'est le
poids le problème ou est-ce que c'est
pas les habitudes de vie puis c'est pas
plus second degré qu'on devrait regarder
oui pourquoi selon ses habitudes de
ville puis suivant contre la crise et
bien peut-être que yeux des composantes
de santé mentale de stress ou autre
chose qui vaut bien mieux que toi tu
sens bien sois heureux et peut-être que
c'est vraiment plus on sentit avait
troqué sur le poids de travailler ta
santé mentale jour qui est toujours déçu
de tape toujours sur la tête du temps
tout en poche parce que t'as pas réussi
at n'est pas deuxième métier dans le
fond on l'a dit hier 1 88% à 3 592%
chances 2-2 d'échec pipe in pipe dans le
fond tout le travail en amont c'est sur
la santé mentale et non sur ton pot
c'est acceptable manque on aurait
beaucoup une société beaucoup plus en
santé sont fous que c'est là dessus
plutôt que deux matches sur le poids
parce que le fait d'avoir mis le focus
sur le poids que ça nous a fait ça nous
a créé des dites car ici c'est une
nouvelle nouvelle pile c'est la nouvelle
à la mode tout le monde paie ce budget
dans le monde arrête un moment donné
tout le monde et ce phoque
le système qui la tête parce que le te
dis je suis pas je suis pas capable je
pourrais soutenir ma diète
j'ai su retomber dedans tu fait le yoyo
avec ton poids ce que c'est on sentait
que de manière générale quelqu'un qui
est quelqu'un quelqu'un qui fait qu'ils
mangent bien et qui fait du sport
notamment savoir un impôt avoir
quelqu'un qui était mauvaise at il dit
il ya des gens croyaient des exceptions
mais de manière générale qu'il est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment obèses tôt
jeudi paume où l'apparence et je
m'accuse pas l'apparence ici logement
crise jamais quand tu pas qu'on devrait
pour son apparence et critique ce soit
soit obèses que tu sois printemps sauf
que de manière générale j'ai
l'impression de ce que j'ai tout le
temps sauf à dire je vous fait dire
aussi il ya des liens d'obésité entre
mettons justement les maladies
cardiaques et le diabète de type 2 et
que j'étais recrosio yad'autres entarté
l'hypertension le taux de cholestérol
moi tu veux avant tout seul puis avoir
un poids santé un truc worry qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses en fait c'est comme
le poids c'est la chose qu'on voit et
qu'on voit maintenant stimatix on va
juger quelqu'un par rapport à son poids
mais tu peux aussi à être maigrichon
fumée et nous avons les pires habitudes
de vie puis tu peux avoir quelqu'un
comme christine original utilise le
terme tome de forte taille sauveur comme
beaucoup qui vivent dans des corps plus
large
we say say say say michaelsen terme très
de traduction automatique d'actions 10
mai mais un peu comme ces pourriels la
taille de quelqu'un c'est la même chose
que de dire bientôt les cheveux blonds
tous les cheveux bruns et c'est encore
le fameux polymères
on n'a pas la même forme on aperçoit
tout cas la même personne avec les mêmes
jeunes
dépendamment de ces épisodes de vie voir
un corps différent ben on va avoir une
santé différent mais sans expérience
mais je comprends ce que vous dites que
le pour l'apparence paul solet c'est un
symptôme de l'autre chose ne s'est pas
la finalité
thomas exact ça vient avec autre chose
mais on a toujours juste mis ça sur le
poids scott quand tu te mets à croire
que c'est le poids qu'il problème parce
que finalement c'est ce qu'on pense on
pense que ce groupe c'est seul problème
mais c'est juste soft voici la lettre
était plutôt que de traiter toutes les
divisions
c'est ça le gros problème on est donc tu
as des gens qui vont te des gens qui
vont dire mais peu importe la façon dont
tu perds ton post pas grave le la c'est
à 50 livres de trop faut que tu perds du
poids des cas précis des gens et le
retour d'éclaircies mais titulaire mais
la joie je me dois perdre du poids tout
est en meilleure santé
tu peux te faire vomir après tes repas
aussi tu vas avons encore on va être
plus que selon les standards de
boutiques sont mis de l'avant par la
société souhaite en meilleure santé non
il ya plein de façons très très très
malsaine que les gens vont utiliser pour
se rendre par ce poids sont hélas pas ce
qu'on leur dit évidemment dans
l'apparence mais aussi parce qu'on leur
dise est mince c'est mieux m'en sentais
aussi évidemment que ces gens ne sont
pas en meilleure santé ars qui vont
utiliser donc c'est pas le poid
nécessairement qu'on devrait traiter
mais tout qu'est-ce qui est auto qui se
rend compte que c'est des individus qui
est des raisons r2 qui donc oui le ça
vient avec autre chose puis oui ç'a un
impact sur la santé mais c'est pas le
seul facteur une plein d'autres à tenir
en compte depuis longtemps d'un billet
que c'est juste ça qu'on garde ou pré
sensé que c'est comme devenu vraiment un
des points les plus importants
qu'aujourd'hui ça a changé parce qu on
le fait moins même des fois pratiquement
félin inverse une certaine époque je me
souviens ainsi publiquement
on applaudit c'est quelqu'un qui avait
une perte de paul c'est dans la société
suis pas beaucoup mais mettons j'ai deux
équipes du contre exemple de ce le plus
grand guardian the biggest loser cette
semaine oui mais voilà les missions des
cats la semaine de quatre jours sa paire
de jumeaux course et se sait que si on
gagnera sobre dans sa chair de poule on
devrait pas dire dans sa perte de poids
monde à vrai dire dans sa lancée
changements d'habitudes de vie c'est
qu'on aurait dû paraître
est ce que parce que à moins qu un mois
qui a déjà de bonnes habitudes de vie
qui ajuste sa polo parce qu'il fait de
même
je connais pas non sauf bug qui présente
mais si en fait c'est que c'est très
s'est amené là on en parle ce mec
ouvrière comme justement bbc news où
toutes ces missions le jodo si c'est
toujours le même concept high rider mais
non mais c'est ici nommons pendu 9,7 fin
du show business avec la perte de poids
en allemand mais puis vraiment de ya
comme un tue c'est presque même ses
habitudes de vie on les ridiculise
mathis et comme que c'est en tout cas
moi je comme un malaise avec ce parce
que tu es justement thé au kebab
ok tu veux changer des habitudes de vie
mais c'est encore une fois pour revenir
au contexte
au delà de ce que tu choisis naître dans
ton assiette si ces cantons contexte ci
dessus je m'en excuse
ses troupes de combat dans le trouble de
comportement alimentaire derrière ce
est-ce que d une situation financière
qui te permet ou te permet pas de manger
d'une certaine façon est ce que tilikum
plein plein plein plein de questions
puis le tout ce qui est mis de l'avant
ce genre moi je mange sion il fait un
petit topo de pourquoi prendre son
absence le topo à lui métier de ses
habitudes de vie qui n'ont pas de bon
sens mais c'est comme un peu ridiculisé
et et puis moi ridiculiser les habitudes
de vie ou le poids de quelqu'un comme ça
marche pour moi pis s'ils s'appuient
encore une fois c'est un exemple parmi
tant d'autres et même pas je n'en veux à
personne dans cette histoire parce que
encore une fois on est dans ce paradigme
c'est normal puis témoin de à cause du
mythique jésus que j'exerce mais je
côtoie beaucoup de
d'être québécois synchro des pâtes au
tournage puis on en parle évidemment
comme chez nutritionniste même pose des
questions oui ça ça arrive qu'on a des
discussions là-dessus il ya énormément
de gens qui sont obsédés par leur poids
dans ce milieu là mais pourquoi vous
pensé parce que ils se font écrire des
commentaires constamment des gens comme
est repris du poète a perdu du temps
était beau et ils sont toujours ils sont
scrutés puis leur corps leur apparence
et leur gagne pain dans la vie et donc
c'est d'une population super à risque
les athlètes les mannequins les vedettes
tout le monde que leur corps est mis de
l'avant dans la société s'est dit
population très très à risque notamment
de troubles alimentaires mais justement
parce qu'ils ont toujours toujours 30 et
leurs produits 2 on commente encore le
poids des gens tout le temps tout le
temps c'est encore la mort mais on le
commande ou six bougies
j'ai deux exemples de situations où est
ce que c'est un peu l'inversé ça me rend
tout aussi mal à l'aise on dirait
mettons une des plus grandes vedettes
mondiales chanteuse adele qui a eu comme
une bonne perte de poids m'amener b
recevait d'émettre des critiques déjà tu
veux quitter l'internât de beauté
nananan de change et blabla des
critiques entre elle a probablement tous
amélioré ses habitudes de vie elle est
une perte de poppy l'aspect critique et
pour ceux ci tout pour moi c'est aussi
absurde oui tu as quelqu'un de toute
façon socke est ici on devrait payer des
gens qui s'identifie prend le maquis une
frange des personnes qui s'identifient à
elle pour son apparent souci parce que
parce que c'est plus rare parce que
encore je pense aujourd'hui on priorise
dans l'espace public des gens des camps
plus filiforme et aux pieds elle a sauté
de là nombre de cinq ans m bravo puis à
qui s'est passé lors du succès en ayant
ce cas le mail aussi à part du pot on
devrait quand même
soit rien dit ou soit féliciter
quelqu'un qui a vu des meilleures
habitudes de vie l'été on devrait juste
rien dire parce que tu sais rien de la
vie de ce poste la série qu'est ce que
mange parce que tu sais qu'est ce qu'ils
font dans leur vie café rase la culotte
quatre ans m
c'était interminable et son prochain
avance un jardin mais une autre
situation c'était la nique ph à cette
expression double et aventi clapet à
l'anis qui est là qui était le symbole
des critiques étaient loin tu vois ça en
faire une petite parenthèse le terme
groupe c pour 107 péjoratif ont leur
rendu péjoratif ça décrit quelque chose
ça c'est du camp sur moi quand je vois
maintenant 10 carats de comparer un show
maintenant un show gauche gros show puis
un petit chien y en a point qu'ils
jugent sur le choc juge pas un gros show
ces juges faut que tranquille keystone
6-4 4-6 le mot grosse et grocaut près à
quoi tu es personnes grosses qu'au prix
d'un bel effort et c'est pas grave et il
est content gros si gros comparativement
à la norme fac-ci collection qu'il le
paraît bref que quelqu'un qui est plus
grands titres du quelqu'un qui est grand
ouais il pris qu'un petit mois stu
méchant non c'est par rapport à la
moyenne aussi pour un cas par exemple
fait par rapport à la moyenne pas moins
non pas la norme et la moyenne mais bref
alanis cette passion au double si la cie
comment dire c'est la seule qui
appauvrit peau du super six mais est
super rebelle
c'est pas beau corps le pays bon bref
schiller en sortant d'être le corrige
aussi si et si je me trompe ou si
l'histoire
ah le à mener dans les mois qui suivent
une perte de pop le tout le monde
justement qui avaient applaudi le fait
que quel soit que passion double avec ce
cas là la critique ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'elle a commencé à s'entraîner
puis on à se montrer au jam une fois par
jour puis à montrer qui a fait une
démarche pour améliorer ses habitudes de
vie pile à toutes les personnes qui
s'est associé à elle parce qu'ils
étaient un symbole de diversité
corporelle à occupation double se sont
mis à un peu lui taper dessus en disant
et la caisse tu fais de plus elle a
répondu aux mails moi je m'entraîne je
veux juste reprendre mes habitudes de
vie parce que j'avais pas des habitudes
saines je laisse me reprendre en main
puis peut-être que ça va occasionner une
perte de poids peut être que non aussi
mais ce beau mais c'est ce que j'ai
trouvé
j'ai trouvé mais une des choses que je
trouve vraiment déstabilisant dans le
livre
hunted haye c'est ce c'est que oui
effectivement comme fo faut être capable
de voir la culture de la diète qui est
omniprésent partout partout partout
partout partout et changer notre façon
c'est pis mais moi j'ai jamais c'est
recommandé de djata personnes outils
chéreau dans la restriction quoi que ce
soit mais même dans certains mots parce
que c'est ce qu'on apprend c'est ce
qu'on lit c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend parler dans
les médias tout le temps fait qu'on
reprend cette information le t2 de
parler de santé puis d'obésité puis de
pop hits sorti mais pas tellement de
poids mais bref je me suis questionnée
beaucoup sur la façon de parler de
l'alimentation du pari de la santé mais
jusqu à un moment donné où je voyais que
gisèle livre je me disais ok mais le
mettons le justement que ça tantôt
d'aller faire
jogging pas sa tante ou de la danse
aérobique pas ce thème se danser ou
n'importe quoi le t2 10 le sport le ca
devrait être la fon puis tu trouves une
activité thème faire le type obligé
d'aller au gymnase pauvreté mais le site
us à petit feu n'était pas complètement
cinglé jeudi comme non mais en fait elle
durant l'hiver le dit le trouver une
activité qui vous fait plaisir immense
dépôt sur la perte de points à perdre du
mouvement puisque de l'exercice s'est
bougé pierre didi bouger ça peut être
d'aller marcher ça peut être d'aller
danser ça peut être de faire le ménage
chez toi petit peu bougé au sipi ou de
prendre ce propos l'escalier roulant ce
mardi c'est comme les métriques défaut
c'est que je trouvais ce com
c'est comme justement le t2 a critiqué
beaucoup l'eurofoot le végétarisme
c'est ce qu'à un moment donné je commets
ok oui parce que l'eau c'est sûr que je
peux facilement aller dans le green it
is born
ouais t'es où comme je t'aime en lutte
leur tour eq si le que tu rentre
rapidement dans l'espèce de peur des
pesticides dit comme ça mais tu peux
quand même dire ok moi je mange des
aliments peu transformé puis posez les
6es je pense que c'est seul message ou
sinon tout se fait dans tout seul tout
ce qu'on dit c'est pas à la fnam en six
ans en fugue
on s'en fou qui genre on s'en fout des
fruits des légumes tout seul ou en fait
dans ce sens on s'en fout d'enfance ou
[Musique]
m'en fou qu'est ce tu mangeras vie pich
paul qui nous comme personne qui
véhiculent l'information n'est pas là
pour te dire tu dois faire ce pour être
en santé parce qu'un il existe une seule
façon décente et bon mais surtout que
doit non de façon si tu décidé que sa
tente pas d'être en santé tout le droit
aussi dans la vie tu peux décider qu'est
ce que tu veux de ta vie fait déjà là
comme faut comprendre que tout droit de
faire ce que tu veux pas drôle de choix
mais j'ai un billet moi je pense que la
santé c'est important
ouais mais je peux comprendre ça s'peut
quelqu'un salle soit pas pendant une
période de sa vie se soit pas une
priorité serait de roi et ce je pense
que c'est important que les gens
réalisent qu'on a le droit de manger ce
qu'on veut prendre de faire ce qu'on
veut parce que en alimentation se met
tellement de
règle dans ce cas-ci d'un type d'action
sur le poids la compagnie même la santé
mais on a tellement de règles conçues en
alimentation que ça devient vraiment
mauvais pour la société se base là tu me
salis mauvais pour notre santé mentale
aussi et c'est juste je veux faire un
point avec alanis de se croiser pour moi
ton exemple ça aurait fait ça fait juste
répéter la même affaire il ya mille
autres sujets intéressants que le poids
des gens à vivre encore une fois c'est
une histoire de contrôler le corps de la
femme celle ci pour lens en tout cas
c'est comme un être ou est trop grosse
sono et rendre trop mais c'est quoi
cette affaire l'homme voyons donc
laisser des gens peu importe leur poids
on a le droit d'exister puis tous les
camps sont valides que je pense que
c'est important de comprendre dans la
société en ce moment les corps qui sont
mis de l'avant ce décor qui sont plus
minces de manière générale donc double
un thème tout pourquoi ce qu'on parle
autant du décor plus large de toute
cette question la grossophobie mais tous
les corps en droit d'exister puis aucun
devrait être commentés ou qu'un devrait
quand même être prêté un tig couvertures
de magazines de la perte de poids toute
personne doit y avait qu on sorte de
cette mission on va arrêter de manger la
viande avant
la bonne nouvelle juste avant de vous
laisser partir juste faire un genre de
rapport avec tout qui végètent à
l'isthme comme la lune tantôt vu les
diètes mode amené d'amener une nuance
parce qu'on compare souvent les diètes
en parlant la diète vegan en disant que
si une diète moi c'est loin la perte de
poids c'est loin d'être dans mon optique
là si je mange des passions flat qui
sont des gâteaux vachon vegan par par
inadvertance agace les doritos je ferai
pas des plats surgelés on s'attend que
c'est pas d'abord fous de cuisine chez
vous le semba ski ultime pour perdre du
poids c'est vraiment passer le message
c'est vraiment pas su comment moi je le
vis tu fais des fois qu'on parle de vega
nice puis qu'on dit que c'est une diète
j'ai de la difficulté avec ça puis je
tenais je voulais juste intégré la
nuance le dans la discussion là parce
que je crois pas que c'est la même chose
ben moi j'ai pas une sans que j'utilise
tout le temps comme ça sans vraiment
penser le mais je dis toujours comme
l'alimentation watts est ce parce que
pour moi c'est comme j'espère que tu
peux manger sens restreint il est encore
là bien évidemment dans les misérables a
bien mais c'est zéro restrictif quand tu
commences à le faire alice qu'est ce que
tu peux faire et surtout qu'est-ce que
tu en as fait une bûche notre deux chats
noël c'est sûr que si on a beaucoup
parlé des aliments être transformé
bernard et moi les gars nous parce que
c'est ce que je voulais parler aussi
quand on compare les débits en 2006 à
faire l'outil mois sur personnellement
ça me dérange petit lait bio médical
peut ben moi j'en mange peu et j'en
mange quand je vais au sw mettons mais
j'en achète pas chez nous j'ai jamais de
deux fosses viande hachée nous embarque
un mais tombe justement voie dès ce 6
juin
mais tu sais pas moi qui va les acheter
mettez en même temps c'est ça c'est
comme moi j'en mange la viande mais
comme vraiment pas souvent fait que
c'est souvent témoin des billes en août
0,1 parce que moi je préférais manger un
vrai bon burger que je vais faire moi
même union dans les restos qui sont
excellents je préfère de loin mais mais
un moment donné tu es si je sais j'en
mange des chips et avec plein de saveurs
des additifs sur d'affaires j'utilise
sasp gens mangent la piste du pepperoni
le spa - transformé cadet des soucis du
stade josé un moment donné les à niveau
on en mange en masse le du stock faut
pas non plus toujours tapis sur le fait
comme à et il levait garde manger un
truc trop transmis de la fosse viande
natixis de mario dumont fait une colonne
je pense que c'était ou encore un sms
qui il démontrait les aliments
d'ambiguïté a les ingrédients ouais les
ingrédients mais comme deux choses la
même chose avec n'importe quoi mario
dumont une sommité en nutrition
non mais bref c'est comme matisse art
bien ce que tu disais le bernois dans le
fond tu peux bien manger ce que tu nous
là on entre sionistes notre formation
c'est de donner des conseils aux gens
basée sur la science pour améliorer la
santé oms niveau là pour dire que c'est
des règles à suivre qui même quand on
dit que a les éléments être transformé
c'est un impact néfaste sur la santé
oui c'est vrai la sens nous dit ça mais
après ce jamais je ne dois pas le droit
d'en manger ou jamais de demander au
fond c'est désormais fièrement
pour moi c'est comme donner des dd de
l'information nutritionnelle basée sur
la science
oui mais comme moi le côté culturel de
l'alimentation haut comme beaucoup plus
d'importance que la l'étude qui dit que
tel un phare c'est comme fixe pour ce
que je reste encore dans le temps la
laddh
couverte utile oui je pense que si on
reste dans un contexte occidental urbain
que oui le la place à la découverte l
école sans fin il ya juste des
possibilités de découvertes puis que
c'est sain c'est certainement pas à
cette impasse sur l'attaquant se jugeant
que con que l'aide de notre alimentation
va être possible
je pense que justement t-il
l'alimentation végétalienne
c'est un modèle alimentaire spawn tiers
des gens qui peuvent le missile total
nuances qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent le
prendre comme une douce et exerce donc
c'est toujours non parce que ça marche
pas c'est au durable ça revient toujours
tous ont servi la même affaire a même
affaire mais n'importe quelles habitudes
alimentaires si tu sens une restriction
cela marchera pas donc oui le
végétalisme ça peut devenir est un type
de 10 pour certaines personnes mais ça
marchera pas sur le long terme si il
faut aussi je pense que pour ses pour
les gens qui sont qui sont peut-être pas
aussi dans leurs étapes de changement
peut-être que de ces temps de rester
dans l'espèce de écoutez si tu fais un
potage de lentilles et tout ce que tu es
chez toi c'est du bouillon tollé le
programme des faux pas qui tape sur la
tête c'est que je n'ai pas fait un bon
temps je vais garder comme il faut
vraiment y aller comme paris je pense
que la majorité des gens c'est vrai
qu'il ya des gens qui vont plus se dire
qu'il faut que clotilde reiss et demain
matin je mange
aucun produit animaux mais je pense que
pour la plupart des jantes de dire je
vais ajouter les végétaux plus de
végétaux juste honnêtement c'est juste
vraiment alphone puis vraiment bon là
c'est fini c'est je pense que ceci c'est
6 c'est une chose qu'on peut faire
collectivement c'est sous ces puisque ça
va faire savoir un impact énorme s'est
autant sur la santé que l'environnement
que les tickets ne le dis toujours s'il
ya aussi tout le monde sait la planète
mange vegan une fois par semaine c'est
comme s'il y avait un milliard devait
même temps c'est vrai
merci infiniment en séduction là c'était
vraiment et on a encore plus de temps
que pendant ce salon des jeunes non mais
on va trouver ça court mais demain quand
on est tellement en fait la réalité
c'est qu'on n'est pas dans la
restriction on est plutôt dans le
fignolage grâce au réalisateur
on dit souvent des discussions de
confiance en lui pour garder le juste le
best on vous écoute où on vous suit où
on vous pour le monde qui nous écoutent
le qui ont apprécié section qui veulent
en avoir plus bas on s'appelle et ont
des jeunes est disponible sur
l'application audio de radio canada mais
maintenant sauf à y tourner vers l'est
où elle sort actuel goûter je sais pas
oui sinon sur le site deadline n'a pas
défailli je pense que nous allons non
pas 40 que bref quand même facile à
trouver
pis non bay sur instagram moi c'est une
triste downeast urbain puis moi je perds
ma copine parce qu'à la fin dans sa
période de jeûne chez thomas continue on
s'écarte lefa s'est hâté et le feu bdf
fait parce qu'on s'était fait dire au
début par là la preuve est parfait merci
énormément
merci